foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they can't hear you now
[Music]
just so you all know I will be going
probably silent every now and then just
make sure I'm doing stuff for the site
thank you so much
I try to liven it up back in 2018
[Music]
fix the screens all right I got it I
haven't done it
do that
what do you do how do you do it
I don't know I'm just watching it on a
steam yeah if you guys you guys watched
on Steam you can possibly get a deck
oh okay you try to get okay you try to
get that free 99 [ __ ] man it's expensive
three men in there free Fair it is like
the I think it's like the 5.99 version
or 6.99 version so it's like you know
what you might as well just go for it
ACG will not be here
they think because his name's their ACG
his face is ACG was there when we did
the the crown your lord so that's why
he's in there
[Music]
well dang I didn't want to talk to HCG
anyways today I gotta fix the uh
okay dead cells has like a Castlevania
thing going on
what's the what's the um somebody sent
me the link
um I'm watching on Steam I know you
watch okay I meant to say uh attic send
me send me the link that you're using
hold on one second
what is it twitch what is it uh yeah
it's YouTube
YouTube okay
I don't really care you gotta tell me
where you want to go
because one of those streams faster than
another one of usually I spiritually
beat twitch is always faster
wow
oh snap I got us in Johnson yeah
so good and what better way to segue
into our first award of the night for
best mobile game
Childish Gambino
Marvel snap one yep Marvel snap I just
told you that now you late see the
Twitter's ahead
if you're trying to sabotage me just
have them both open Watch the switch
Yeah that's what I'm doing I'm using the
review laptop player
well we'll snap in the building put my
score at my points
[Music]
where my points at me uh starting a new
company is
back said it's four addicts and only one
car you rigged
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to homestick isn't it great
Snap Yo vampires everywhere I think
that's what they just said Discord
server to discuss tonight
oh yeah mobile
you folks have phones yeah
oh no it's going to Mobile buckle up for
three World premieres in a row I mean
it's not like they can't run it
is a game yeah
this world premiere
oh jansen's in here what oh my God
all that and he's already in here oh
Valley of Hearts right
oh Valiant Hearts
stop doing drugs be the bull attack oh
yeah
well it looks like they said the name of
the kitchen before I put you in the
thing yes before I put you in the thing
change your name
[Music]
no PlayStation Studios oh two brothers
[Music]
hosting
Chicago
you ain't do what I'm doing on here
I like it let me get to do all the work
I get to complain I love it
it's coming relax he's figuring it out
oh return on PC yeah stop talking about
it they get mad cause they can't return
last year at the game
we will get it right all I can say is
don't worry guys we'll narrate for you
it's up there drunken Ninja
no I I have to physically put everyone
in the show spending way too much time
enough of that
but they're is plenty more opening oh
Samsung TV with gaming oh look it's
ninja playing as ninja
very famous game fortnite wow
what you got for me is there 60 frames
patch
your favorite Bluetooth controller and
starting today right now you can play
the Xbox app on any Samsung 2021 Smart
TV hey boss it's going crazy
so what are you waiting for what's going
on
what up live Supremacy what up
how can you tell
[Music]
I heard the same thing happened it was
good man Jackson I'm doing you last
because you want a video
oh I knew it oh that's fine hey is there
any way I can mute the audio from your
guys's stream yeah mute the audio from
our dreams
yeah I hear everything playing through
you guys oh chat oh don't watch it you
watch it on IOP YouTube channel
no it's the video from The Game Awards
playing over you guys it's weird well
then what you want to do is you want to
uh take the you just want to mute our
stream and just watch yeah yes
oh no I get what you're saying I'm
saying in the zoom call for some reason
the zoom call is projecting me the Video
Game Awards audio
that's weird weird that's weird yeah
look at your audio settings
let me check
I don't think it's coming from Zoom it's
got to be coming from somewhere else
it's got to be coming from like another
tab or something
it was from another tab I'm an idiot
yeah I figured I've had no trust me I've
had that happen to me so I knew what
kind of just over
50 times
[Music]
everything okay oh good honey
yeah that's good I want to see him on
there and I want to see him clap back
like no you give that guy like five
minutes to accept this wolf
that's fighting game what do we have
I didn't even play the game so I'm not
voting on it yeah
I hope everyone is suited up I think I
won that next award s man my points at B
are the nominees hit the double b
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure All-Star Battle
r
the King of Fighters 15.
we are here for activity we already know
Tyler B
and
hello and
it goes to all right Lord John what up
she is either very tall all right so
Cognito ACG and solve one then yeah
where my number
did you update the ticker my family for
all the sacrifices and uh right now I
gotta go to my first game twitch real
quick start up okay startup that we
started the tiles are done also thank
you um Warner Brothers uh for really
whoa
or they cannot go
oh brand new announcement brand new game
what we doing I'm going guys I'm going
World premiere
right so I need to narrate
sorry
the violent Hearts too or something
they show about their hearts earlier
nah it looks like Paw Patrol
um
for adults
I think it's like The Wolf Among Us too
all right there guys that's a weird art
style
for it
you look like they could be a little bit
though on the side but I don't know all
right right there I need you that area
does everyone hear what's going on
what you mean I don't know let me just
bring it up
yeah because they're they're behind a
little bit so
[Music]
I mean I might play that I'm not gonna
lie all right web oh
that graphics
[Music]
I'll show myself out
now I have the honor of announcing it
when your joke was bad does not want to
happen here just saying Esports games
and the game award goes to that's what I
voted
[Applause]
these are
yay we didn't vote for any of these two
so Saul voted valorant who has more
development how did you get that King
voted valorant
where it goes to
last go on do it again
companies are I voted valorant you voted
wow
you voted League of Legends oh yeah
[Applause]
uh Valerian Champions see like here's my
thing we didn't do anything
[Applause]
to be honest but but you get what I'm
saying though if they're going to put
that in why even do it if they're going
to do it back to back it's like I'd
rather that go to someone that you
actually gonna take time to do it's
including a free game from epic Jeff's
Among Us I'm just waiting on them
AKA god of war and now so many world
premieres and only a little bit more
time let's get right to three more
starting with a look at something new in
the Horizon World which is up for game
Horizon still won an award as part of
the game makers Sketchbook so right now
Sal's in the lead damn it damn it here's
a new look at the PS VR2 King is has one
you're kicking ass and me and you are an
ACG are in seconds
oh this is the VR game VR game
oh this is the uh
what they're doing VR for Horizon yeah
yeah
no but here's the thing they said um is
it something new for the ride
that's true that's true yeah like four
times call it a mountain I thought I was
gonna see that um hey chat lay off the
host okay lay off the hose
our chat needs a loves to clown on women
hoes or or thirst the hell out of women
hoes there's no way in between are they
going wait are they actually doing that
are they going after the oh yeah some of
them are some of them say she look real
nice in that dress yeah yeah guys just
go for that commentary but it's
yourselves dude what you gotta do behind
your screen all right
what is interesting
mechanic it looks like you James
as we did as we go deeper
we can't hear you okay
let me turn this stream down just a tad
so they can hear us a little bit better
all right so the screen's a little
messed up let me fix it there's a Gabe
new game
featuring Gabe now
y'all stupid
okay no no it's not for him because it's
coming to console
world for me hey Gabe Newell says he
loves console as long as it starts with
an X
yeah Unity
oh oh I've seen this game
you take like a photo
I'm not gonna lie this game actually
looks really good
[Music]
so okay how does the overlay look
looking good looking good I just don't
like the three besides sauce
everything's fine
everything looks good you know I'm on
the screen so it's all good now oh it's
all good yeah
oh
it's really unique all right so let me
start deleting these as I go they did
best Esports
[Music]
not for me
[Music]
well see they can have exclusivity
remember very intriguing well no the FTC
made
yo yeah yeah
I'm telling you that's gonna bite the
FTC in the ass
yeah yeah please no it is I mean they
went from Sony being in the books data
products buttocks
atomic heart maybe here we go
places you guys got to play it pay for
this
I see that's how we should do this okay
I I will say this is the first time I've
seen this game that makes me kind of
want to play
what's graphical stuff is actually very
impressive this is the way that it looks
I'm just surprised this is a Russian
game I thought this was like Square Enix
when I first saw it no no if it was
quick it would be on Xbox
with no FTC interference so oh we got
the freedom to do that
he's jumping from the mountains with joy
right now because Microsoft had to make
concessions well guess what if they went
in court they have to make zero
concessions
[Music]
oh we know we know what's this what's
this
hashtag just one energy upstairs
not on Xbox
[Laughter]
Xbox edition
oh look at the little creative weapons
okay uh it's a little too slow to be
returned
for sure oh that was cool I like the
the uh melt in the icing
that's stranding too Scar's above all
Xboxes I want a series X okay oh
it's sorry guys it's still held back by
the PS4 wait it's not held back suddenly
guys
okay this is gonna be a messy stream
with these three
look my kids love this section so
foreign
what
are you gonna review this
um
again
so bad like
the loot thing makes it a little bit
better but it's probably still something
the All-Star is actually not that bad it
kind of got the Gunstar Heroes kind of
mom
s
real talking hey hey we got 273 people
in the chat go on Twitter and say where
you watching this at all right
ambassadors and tonight Verizon has a
special offer on the Xbox series s scan
the QR code below for free and you'll
get a free little man's in the Stream
there we go
a special deals can be free and I have
to say I want you to know I love all my
world premieres equally and I try not to
play favorites
sure but I have to admit I am extra
excited about this one here's a special
announcement from Among Us
meta platforms
you know I would really I would try this
on VR with you guys well you need to get
down if you need to get down with us me
as soon as I'm waiting
what is this
[Music]
it's hide and seek hide and seek trying
to think yeah oh why do they gotta keep
Dead games alive
hey yo geez that's me what I eat coffee
that's me when I drink coffee
we could solve getting away
body
you know what's crazy this is probably
gonna breathe Crazy Life into this game
yeah
okay but can't just ask something we're
going to space who's not giving any of
these guys a gun they know this stuff's
happening
the fence packs of heat
new game mode out December 9th
oh tomorrow
that's that's how you make an
announcement coming out tomorrow
coming out tomorrow
well just give me the third time of
seeing hellblade that's all I want
[Music]
the fifth showing of Halo please but you
saw us looking at the stream and like oh
I already went and bought it yeah that's
the perfect game to take a break and
write something uh you know that car
what's up so I'll probably look at the
stream I'm winning by one
all right all right all right
this looks like a PlayStation game
oh God don't who needs King here what do
you got smooth here
no problem suppose like it's okay you
you take a break today
actually I'll play this Nintendo Vibes
to be honest
I might be on the switch
Snoopy would play uh
smooth Play Snoopy Adventure but won't
play this
Paw Patrol you play PAW Patrol too
smooth won't play this
I play this if it's not on PlayStation
so if it came to Game Pass it's lit we
lit right
I see the rules let's see the rules of
the game wiener dog there we go
sorry that's all I can think of
interesting
it does look really interesting I'll
give it that after us it's on Xbox One
just so you know oh gosh
this is the next gen only game
I think my New Year's resolution
Let's Help Batman the series well if
you're streaming tonight you can see
these seats filling up behind me we're
getting ready to kick off Gaming's
biggest night yo this is a switch game
at the bottom of our mic
that's how you plug the mic it's a whole
new game
World premiere next year this is on Game
Pass replaced right
thousands of American are you guys
already on replaced
let me rephrase
where are you watching this movie twitch
twitch I'm watching on Twitch and I
ain't on replaced yet
don't talk out of trying to figure it
out
when it comes to the game awards smooth
don't don't say those out loud because
you're a little bit ahead
my bad it's cool I don't care about the
announcements but not the uh the awards
see this art style looks good I like
games like this
and this definitely looks like something
Xbox would sponsor
Ah that's what we do
yeah I'm serious house I swear
well we will know if it's not on Game
Pass they definitely didn't sponsor
because Xbox dudes don't pay for games
this is all game pass this is all game
business yeah yeah makes sense I
remember to smoke here this one that
little dark Vibe a little cyberpunk
joint
[Music]
and it was pretty visceral about them
[Music]
[Music]
all right
what's that game that looks like this
that never came out the last night or
whatever yeah yeah
that game's been in concept for 10 years
they just took the project renamed it
replaced
[Applause]
I can't be you know oh one time best
family let's go Paw Patrol
all right so here's the here's what we
did solve Splatoon 3 King Lego attic
Lego Cognito logo ACG logo we don't win
Legos
oh if I'm trying to go for the win okay
Kirby and the Forgotten lands all right
Kirby one Lego Star Wars the Skywalker
Saga Lego Lego Lego Lego Lego come on
man
don't say anything to your head
[Applause]
let go let go and the game awards
I'm okay with that though I'm okay with
that that's why we got Bowser in the
building thank you so much I am a little
annoyed that a game like that will win
game of the year I would win family win
it's not really a family game and
Nintendo that worked on Kirby not to
mentioned I don't know any kids
would be cool to see this little cute
but houses outside
and all he had to do was go full
mouthful mode on a giant car to do
thanks again for this
thank you
you're so scared to mine I'm sorry
totally snatched that
and finally
I have a world premiere that is a trip a
franchise that has this is 35 years and
still going strong has yet another
installment for you it's Bioshock World
premiere
are you trying to be wrong
I didn't ask for your opinion on the
matter
good DJ from um
Oh I thought it was the dude from uh
Dead Island
[Applause]
[Music]
that dude is like five seconds away from
being like looking like kids movies yeah
okay kid
yes let me get that representation you
got that reach too smooth
he was obsessed to yourself
but finding an appropriate vessel
damn it's Jim Ryan
no
man only
your heart
very colorful
oh
that's shaking she is not playing
Ryan what's going on that is in the
house so I salute
chat you might as well say something
he
come out at the very end and say
something
yeah boy
he's only up by one
[Music]
battle Hub okay
foreign
[Applause]
at least it's on uh Xbox in general
though yeah that's good at it in Mr
platform I mean we can't ignore the
market leader okay everyone Papa dog
what up
Big Show we're
working with musical performances and
even yeah I'm looking for that second
two Jack Brown With You
368 and hit that like y'all hit that
like the world of gaming is thriving
right now we have tons of game content
to show up it's so thriving Sony raising
their prices
so
is it a huge congratulations we got 369
people in here man hit that like button
let's get that over to over 115 20 likes
yeah I know you guys could do that stop
being lazy there's a little there's a
little thumbs up button on your on your
screen
now
all right here we go here we go yeah
disappoint me sir let's go was goody
looking clean out there man it's looking
nice
midnight Sun's life yeah very midnight
sun energy
out here why just the one buttons
don't say it alone I'll make my own
to have the entire industry with us here
tonight let's go oh we got the Velvet
what you know about the Velvet I don't
even know about that flame well I say
hello to all the nominees uh Mr Miyazaki
great to have you here you need that
velvet okay okay
everybody
yeah yeah
of course oh
no doubt he said yo all right
Phil's here's an alibi and everything
they stand for Phil's here is an alibi
Joseph
yeah yeah
animals here guys
that's not the muppets again I could
have took that seat FTC all up in your
game decision all up in your
Acquisitions
thank you for being a part of this
community tonight we are going to honor
the best games of the year
one of the best games of the year within
15 seconds Bill did not look happy I
agree Childish Gambino feel did not look
at it Star Wars Jedi Survivor right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time for
I am so honored to welcome one of the
great actors of course it's an actor
he's a two-time Tony winner a two-time
Emmy winner
an Academy Award winner
oh we'd have got the budget hey yo we
just got a budget up we got out let's go
let's go dude probably ain't played a
game in his whole life and he's up there
giving an awards
let's go
thank you hello everyone
he's ready which game were you
forgetting it's really good to see you
here
oh this is uh yeah yeah I was up there
oh gee be respectful by them be
respectful
as usual doing my surprising thing to
myself anyway
uh I I
come on now
but anyway
uh but uh in the in truth
I don't play oh no no no no
what I do have however spent a lot
watching my kids oh god oh good and I've
continued to be thoroughly That's all
folks we leave it where's the kingdom
all right
I could just hear
Keely in the back of man why did you say
that like I already man stick to the
teleprompter Man actually you know
what's funny they're gonna let this man
talk longer than the dude that actually
gets the rule he got mad
[Music]
help tell these stories
he's looking at Keeley are you serious
look in front of a camera
this part
fundamentally always we're the same
uh we we are all right
yeah mental in the chat yo who got the
rapper where the hook at yo what's going
on and zoom in on Phil's face
or was that a part of the bit
[Music]
[Music]
came on here to give an award he's
talking about acting this is the [ __ ]
I'll be talking about I think he might
be freestyling because he can't see or
something but what's going on even if
best performance
immortality Kingston immortality I said
a plague Cognito you said God of War and
ACC said to play a game so here they got
Blake tail records yeah yeah like I got
it I got Christopher George
you know
I'm taking ownership if I win either
Christopher okay
best performance
wow
the best performance
winner
oh wow
yeah
you saw Jeff put it quickly judge out
early to let y'all know how to do
[Applause]
I'll do it later I'll put it up now
I have fun with this
they sent you the tone for y'all now
we're gonna have a PlayStation
celebration FDC knocked out the deal oh
it's going down today gold suit
now I see why I couldn't get more than a
plus one
um
he designed it though he did a good job
Awards
I just finished 28.
I have to thank my mama shot the mama
Joe
who's
belief that I would amount to something
good would uh never waver even though it
looked like I'd never amount to anything
good
um my brother
who's my hero
at 40.
changed his life
went to medical school and has now died
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not gonna lie his shoes are pretty tight
my children outfit is crazy
you got a three besides your name is
this here gold it's a gold laminate it's
crazy
it looks like our the back of our shirts
um
forever it's crazy proud of
forever thankful of and still the best
role I've ever had is being your dad all
right
all right all right brother
did he win last year too I don't know
you know what's funny solve convinced me
not to Tony Santa Monica
that's not my name I blame you have it
no I like it I like it Miss Yumi yang
it is an honor and a pleasure
you are a unicorn because keep it moving
Chris wrap it up for the first time ever
the trickle-down Theory actually worked
thank you
yeah also d-mom and Def Jam yup fight
for the facts thank you uh wait he was
in Def Jam
fight for New York having me wrong I
love that girl
um oh
I was the last actor in California to
read for it
um and Corey they about to hit him with
the wrapping up they got to do it on the
side they get to do it yeah they said
bro if you don't get off the stage
up to 10 minutes
got five seconds on stage Matt just
saying Rich yeah Joseph Ferris is Iconic
though
sacred
uh everyone
everyone
designer be it chill whatever it was who
worked
under extraordinary he's still talking
okay
yo I might as well just cook something
okay he really is gone a little too long
Jeff's gonna be mad at us you say yo
y'all Toby I'll be cutting them off and
look what happened Justin okay Jeff like
I told Jets on the side like throwing
little rocks at him it's wrapping up
he's doing some time
uh I I think it's kind of common
knowledge that uh
honored to go to get all this word you
get 2018 speech dupes and When Corey
took me outside and said he wouldn't be
directed one last one Lego had to switch
they're exactly they had to get you back
and he said no give it a life story
I vouch for Eric
and I said
Eric Williams better be a beast
thank you oh
Chris I'm okay
I'd rather than let him talk than the
dude that presented like relate yeah
fair enough to Corey on he given the
whole backstory kind of a artistic level
I don't know man this is just as bad as
opportunity on that side of me
so
[Music]
but two from a very similar
the chat is getting rested what if they
just let him keep going
what if we're here
he's like what if they put a new policy
that you can't interrupt
he just did so deeply and because it's a
timely frame that
cinematics have to fit into uh get your
beers off the stage hopefully not
speeches
um
all right
childhood memories oh man
I love you but now we do got to move on
a little bit
somebody said
[Applause]
words I will never forget at that five
years old
he said this man Chris judge treat the
street it's like a podcast
oh my God
[Laughter]
brought as much they said turn the
volume up on the stream a little bit so
we get all this right dude
I have to turn you guys down more though
said we agree to two minute rounds Chris
you can't keep getting he broke the
camera
[Applause]
for you yeah
Dreamcast guy wrap it up Yoki what is he
cooking uh Kofi wrap it up Chris Ray gum
I love Kratos but sit down please the
two things I hopefully gave you
hire me the orchestra
he literally
they playing music yeah they are he
literally applying for the next job
to every single person
because you got so many people in the
world through a very difficult Dark
Times
yeah
escapism and and just being bad it's
still going
um
have a great night you know I know he
was way too long but I'm okay with it
I wasn't
good I'm okay with it like here's the
thing though like
oh my God you noticed it
Chris judge I think he was trying to
give him away as well all right
it's rolling here at the game awards
top studios are here at the game awards
to give you a glitch such an exciting
future of video games in 2023 and beyond
our first world premiere company small
but highly acclaimed Studio that needs
no introduction at this point and whose
last game earned multiple Awards here at
TGA I'm very excited to share the global
announcement of their next project here
we go everything getting raced up now
I'm cool with that though man that that
I like stuff like that though like he
got emotional like I'd rather that
happen than not Giant games oh God
people made Hades
a cool guy
oh no Ninjago scarecrows
yeah this is what we're here for
so can you turn the stream volume up
[Music]
everyone makes their music
yeah
that's as far as I'm willing to go
before it blows my years off
good
oh there's Hades music that's the 80s
music
greatest
hits
Kratos
[Music]
oh my God
here we go Apollo is like your way down
[Music]
not ready to give in no I was born
again they said the game okay okay
[Music]
woman
I'll be this bit loud okay now it's too
loud
[Applause]
all right tell me if that's a good
mixture he's still mad about Christopher
Giant games like the original which was
revealed here at TGA in 2018 Hades 2 is
going to be developed in Early Access so
your feedback can help shape the game
and news on Early Access is coming in
2023. next I'm so excited about this one
we're taking a journey to an exciting
New World with a world premiere from a
studio led by someone with a legacy of
building incredible narrative driven
games and creating genre defining
experiences it's moments like this
about the future all right everyone be
quiet narrative
I'm gonna Riot everyone be quiet don't
don't rude
oh BioShock
all right I'm intrigued it's dying
and my only way out of here
is with one of them
I [ __ ] with it
[Music]
[Music]
it's got Kim the vine written all over
it man let's go let's go it does have
that energy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
world
s
baby
not an alfredo truck moment but of
course
you surprises tonight that was a first
look at Judas coming from Ghost Story
games led by Kevin you called it it's
created immersive gaming World
a few months ago I visited the studio in
Boston and played multiple hours of this
game and let me tell you everything you
saw there is an in-engine ghost story
games is also exploring different
approaches to narrative that you will
learn about in the future let me just
say I can't wait for them to tell you
more didn't that look fantastic yes it
did man thank you Jeff get them off the
stage all right well let's go to another
brand new game announcement for the fans
here at the game awards oh he didn't go
into detail this is going to be big
Platinum uh
what last letter Bayonetta
DLC
I hope it's not DLC can we get enough of
this game man can this game go somewhere
or is it a remake I swear to God it was
a remake
what should I say Nintendo baltim
[Music]
prequel
radio
[Music]
or something
someone said no thanks
um
[Music]
how is this even Bayonetta yeah I'm
trying to get the connection
if you look at it
[Music]
give me the cliff nose version
race
I hate this character
don't do it well like
really cute you know that girl get her
uh voice acting job
you're messy dude
chat forgive them
that looks like the definition of a
switch game I'm sorry yeah they might
have they might have lost me on this one
yeah yeah you called it you called it
flame called it y17 not for me but maybe
someone
it's over okay okay
somebody says switches for the kids
hold on so you're telling me Nintendo
and Playstation are allowed to have
exclusives but not Xbox
[Applause]
play this brand new action adventure
game in the banana series on March the
17th all right there are lots more new
game announcements and awards to come
but tonight you also have a shot at some
cool free stuff just by watching the
game awards on Steam naked that steam
deck flame every minute to a viewer of
the show he literally has Doritos
quicker after Christmas speech but I'm
so happy I don't mind you guys as long
as they're not interested but seriously
steam deck is incredible and you can
watch on steam.tv we also have twitch
viewer rewards Watch 60 Minutes of the
show tonight on our George Channel and
you'll get the limited edition Jeff
Keeley Among Us masks and awesome Kate
Diaz for games costume in Fall Guys and
a full free game
and more we'll be right back with a
spectacular performance from Hozier and
the game
more Awards announcements and yes
we'll be back chef please man people in
the server no more Muppets oh wait
forever we're here for me seeing
everyone in the Discord this world of
passion all right I'm muting the zoom
thing because wow because sometimes like
just things are weird when it comes to
uh
I don't want Oh you mean you're moving
their stream with the advertisers
anyway you know what they're gonna
always hit us you know not getting
through this without getting hit you
know that because they gonna have some
original music or the orchestra
watching new adventures and vast worlds
we did miss some super chats but more
I'm sorry I think it's just wait until
like after this I gotta be a real
respectful
he had a little too much to drink he
feel nice yeah judges in his bag bro
like he was gonna give you his life
story from when it all started I was a
little pup back in 84.
he had to give you all that money all
that
yeah you'll probably go to the
monetization party when it comes to
having fun is the limit
see where the fun takes you in 2023.
oh wow I missed the bus
I missed a bunch I apologize I apologize
all right that's your attic how kind of
Pokemon some of the real they say the
wrong date on it but whatever Xbox
player San Francisco Oh no I got it I
got it okay smart goals
um with two pounds of attack Keely the
FED that rolled in so I go 17 2000 with
you Phil got hands for keighley FTC
watch out yeah Philly he looks spicy
that friend to roll so I go 17 Again two
pounds Super Chat Keely always bring out
people don't care about spawn go 17 two
pounds to the chat his last two brain
cells just left bro WTF 17.
two battles of a chat judge speaks
longer judges speech is longer than um
The Game Eminem diss track
yeah yeah a little too much he was nice
he was getting it all off
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger try all right
I think we are caught up on super chats
we got a five dollar Super Chat from
Lady sand never watched the game awards
before now and I know I know why yeah
you got him you know you got him three
yard Kelly the homie 2002 chat where's
my boy King King has had to work man
baby coming yo they escort judge
what's going on what are you doing he's
bringing video game music to life on
stage he slap some more blood upon the
snow from tonight's motion Jeff was over
there saying dude why did you do that
please welcome multiple Platinum Grammy
nominators
Reggie that's already
there it is oh this is an addicts group
right here turn it up
no I turned it down
turn it up one two one two what is this
it's your choice oh oh yeah yeah
everyone
I'll get one of the announcements while
they're doing this
I guess it's us talking while this is
going on so how you guys feel so far
I will say one thing called you wouldn't
solve retired right now I know see how
long it lasts
[Music]
what's so sad is that they're not going
to present another award for like
another 15 or 20 minutes so you guys are
always going to be tied
mean turn it up
turn my music up B
itch you guys will be fine
but Phil Spencer had the best
acquisition of all time
you saw you try to save the name of
Kanye West so for right now
grab the mic but Phil's not the best
acquisition of all time shout down back
at the Jade yo Stooges and they couldn't
get 21 a drink yo you should
listen man the budget is what the budget
is
they pulled this dude he looked like the
the homeless dude next to the dollar
store
truck and then she got the bushes
you two have an issue if we get all
Kelly to say yo yeah Bessie popped out
check your ACD she'll make this show
crazy wait look on the bright side for
this segment there's going to be at
least five steam decks being given away
so hey how can we do that by the way I
gotta try that go to the game awards uh
tab on Steam right now uh register if
you haven't already and then just watch
the stream I guess
but uh you know Stitch stay here stay
here
[Music]
absolutely Mikasa come on attic you know
you blasted this Orchestra in the whip
at the stoplight oh my God
Stitch the sodium was these some time in
the cooking boring bushes
little Conga they said the judge was so
drunk he thought he was on Joe Rogan
Park wow
huh how do you watch it on Steam
uh if you go to the store go to like the
store tab the home or sorry like
featured and then there should be like a
little Banner okay got it thanks man
I got you
um
watch me win I'll ship that [ __ ] to Cog
right away I don't even care
as soon as I get my pillow
[Applause]
not gonna lie Cog I'm pretty hyped about
that pillow all right the valari
you already know all right we back to
the action all right
by the way how was dumpling no I was it
was lit Mr Pink it was lit had a good
time
amazing what that Orchard puts together
in just a few weeks of rehearsal they'll
be back later in the show to pay tribute
to our game of the year oh the game of
the year
for the game awards on Billy Billy in
China and on our Discord server you can
head over to discord.gg the game awards
tonight to join in the discussion about
the show right now to present our next
award from the new film Glass Onion and
knives out mystery premiering December
23rd on Netflix please welcome Jessica
hennicks
it was acting up yeah we lost like 100.
well I dropped no it's just my internet
I don't want to allow anything like this
after I stream somewhere yeah we've lost
almost 200 viewers now so what happened
it's just YouTube says it's not it's not
getting enough
oh it's not there's broadcast not going
through it's going through it's just
some people are having issues
there's some uh
it might help
anyway I don't want to spoil our film
but I can tell you this is a very
popular video games featured in it and
now to give you some more clues please
welcome writer director Ryan Johnson and
the star of Glass Onion Daniel Craig
[Applause]
a little something yeah
it's very very nice yeah and now
Best debut anyway we got what we got
what's the vote we're Sinners plucked
from hell
and I'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
uh solve stray King stray and the rest
was vampire
hey
but the rest of us have vampires
yeah
yeah
I'll say string
just remember stream I get it out of my
heart
yeah I remember and the game Award for
Best debut Indie goes to
strength
no it doesn't stop with that nonsense I
love that game that was like one of the
best games I played this year
so I made a good choice because the fact
that it was there we go gave me the year
domination a good point
you guys are gonna have to refresh
there you go cat look you got some
representation in your life thank you
thank you so much it's an incredible
Honor on behalf of the whole team in
Montana that is probably watching oh
solves ahead because of that shirt
everyone that was involved in Louisville
oh you were so close yeah
I had to see the signs
did you play the game called I did not
that's why I couldn't talk
pretty damn good
[Applause]
for no reason
um and yeah thank you to the players we
put such a big part of our Lives making
these games I can't remember that ever
happened back to it is the best feeling
in the world so it happens
sorry what's going on I mean I have the
stream up been off the entire time it's
been out for me the whole time certain
people were getting the the buffer
congratulations
your favorite game in the game yeah
the game
it's because of people like
something powerful
it's easy
The Impossible
[Music]
friend oh they got the Spider-Man
Mobility let's go
oh that's crazy look how they
manipulating them
yo that's literally condemned for
Warframe too bad Johnny got a trailer to
give me one
we just um
let's go
literally get jealousy to yourself see
I'm okay with we're coming back I'm okay
we're coming back to the mistress
whatever I got something going on you
know who do this looted shooter
go I just wish you know that college
I'm okay with coming back to the
mistress when things going on where we
Act
hug [ __ ] ain't that it's just one
thing to make a new enemy already I am
so tired oh I'm so happy that you're
getting out here I'm so happy that
you're upset
oh Wonder Woman I'm happy that you are
no Rock Steady stop
oh Batman baby
somebody find the back entrance
[Music]
the door will not hold we must barricade
it he's looking behind it
you stay here pal Suicide Squad
see this I spent a lot of time dreaming
up how I was gonna kill you with
The Flash in the pocket you're mine now
and you're in for a world
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you got to appreciate Harley Quinn
damn Rogue Batman they're gonna get
Batman out of pocket it's a cool twist
I am Vengeance I am the Knight
I am Batman
wait hold up somebody oh explain that to
me there's a bad Batman
you know what they did that because uh
the dude who played Batman just he
passed away recently oh
after 30 years is the iconic voice of
Batman in the Arkham video games Batman
the Animated Series and countless other
DC projects actor Kevin Conroy sadly
passed away last month at the age of 66.
he was such an iconic voice he was so
amazing in the Arkham games and I know
we're all going to miss him dearly well
tonight we can share that he will return
to rocksteady's Arkham verse one final
time to play Batman in Suicide Squad
kill the Justice League when the game
releases oh that was his last voice
[Applause]
now as we think about the next phase of
our industry it's important to recognize
those who represent the bright bold and
inclusive future of gaming that's why we
have our game awards future class
presented by Old Spice and tonight over
75 members of the class from the past
two years are here in the audience hello
guys
[Music]
and this week we inducted the 2022 class
of 50 50 new members you can read about
them at tgafutureclass.com and right now
meet one of this year's new members a
chemist turn Game Dev at inner sloth who
also happens to be a street dancer
I'm Mick mignier I'm the lead back-end
programmer on Among Us and I'm a street
dancer named Dr robotics
I was looking at the movement of NPCs
and video games and realized that we as
animation dancers have the unique
ability to show body control at least
six freaking hat uh what was it the grow
Club
AdSense it's really exciting I think
there's a lot of potential to bridge
these two different art forms
[Music]
all right Chad here we go
[Music]
oh okay
shout to my boy hip-hop game and that
made the commercial put your hands
together for hip-hop game with the
legends
love to see it
y'all know what it is let's go I love
AMD man
that's pretty tough that's tough game
pass
okay requires
you available on TVs FTC stop that
yeah stop bringing video games to people
whatever they have a whole marketing
campaign what you gonna do now
we spent two years
got issues
relax wow
yeah prepare your friends for a cute and
relaxing Animal Crossing likings
this game will improve your relationship
with friends oh brother help me yeah
sure
orange cat Canada Goose [ __ ] wait I
know his name
baby yes for real actual Royal Corgi an
actual orange cat an actual Canada Goose
an actual this is small talk let's
interview the game producer what
inspired you want to make so many
outfits for these cute animals
they kind of lose with the phone taking
place in some of the most epic places
don't try these in the humans
a submarine destroying the world
fighter jet yeah
while the game offers various modes to
encourage different styles of gameplay
but we all know that the only thing
that's really interesting is to watch
your friends lose their [ __ ]
he's doing better
weapons
you know what's funny them just being
really neat so like this down with the
gamers like this is how Gamers speak the
game like scratching it will lead to
this game selling more than the other
one yeah
we getting them factions no it doesn't
oh no it's just a commercial this is the
regular commercial
s
wait that's last one was two already
oh yeah
no hey guys my best edition let's do it
let's do it did it
that's right the last of us is
officially coming to PC on March 3rd and
that game just came out cast of The Last
of Us show from HBO no no no hey yeah
six months
opening act Sydney Goodman
[Applause]
all right which one
what award
[Music]
tonight we're presenting a brand new
Award for best adaptation okay this
award celebration we all said edge
wonders we all said edge Runners Edge
Runners gotta win lovingly Transformers
and television here are the nominees
want to be Sonic I'd be happy if it was
Sonic wait hold on that was such a good
just real quick I gotta say this real
quick that had a concert last year
why is it back in the game
why everyone is airing around
I know but I mean like arcane's there
why is
adaptation I think Edge runners in the
game Award for best adaptation goes to
Arcane League of Legends
you know it's funny someone almost
picked Arcane Somebody almost picked
arcade too
I think it was ACG
we're bombing this year's Game Awards
wow
I mean it's incredible honor to you know
be awarded by the video game Community
you know we're all we're Gamers at heart
uh who built this and uh
it's been a long long journey a lot of
great things about that uh definitely
like to thank uh fortish you know his
amazing animation you see in every frame
of the show uh Netflix has been a
wonderful partner of course
of course Riot you know for believing in
us to Mark Sean and Brandon this is our
uh it's just been it's been an
incredible ride and I
can't thank you enough so once again
thank you
Mr Arcane League of Legends and speaking
of adaptations later we'll have the
first clip from the new Super Mario
Brothers animated movie can't wait to
have that Keegan Michael Keel be with us
all right now back to the games coming
later in the show we'll have an update
on Final Fantasy 16.
a new look at cyberpunk's Phantom
Liberty expansion and the first game
play raw gameplay footage of Tekken
eight there's lots more game awards to
come and that means oh yeah
of a long-awaited game along the way to
the game what big games are showing up
on order yeah but it's not nothing shown
this year
oh
no this is uh Jedi Survivor let's go
sit your blood back down
oh yeah
oh yeah I was betrayed by the one I
trusted most
I will not be imprisoned again baby
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
I'm sorry respawn one of the best people
oh I've been the best man
people just now catching up to what we
don't
know
sorry cause they are better they're
better their whole friend here why
everyone is God
do you even like games playing wait I
know he's going to be mad at stuff Never
March
the players only grown stronger
gotta enjoy life
you know I'm reviewing this today
[Music]
God it looks so good that's what I want
to hear from playing wait what
do you think
I'm calling you to Grouch again
celebrate
oh he's becoming strong dude
[Music]
stop that's it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and I think I can speak for everybody at
respawn EA and lucasfilm when I say how
incredibly excited we are today
I had the chance to play the game
recently and I can honestly say that
this is one of the best Star Wars games
of all time oh I agree it's going to be
the best game I have no doubt that
you'll feel the same way when you
respawn
and I just got to say that I am so
incredibly lucky to be a part of this
incredible project and it's really
something extraordinary so
we'll see you all in a galaxy far far
away March 17th and until then
May the force be with you
respawn throw it up
did you think I was dissing for uh
doesn't that gameplay look incredible I
can't wait to play Jedi Survivor thanks
to respawn and EA for giving us that
first ever look EA is already counting
all that much I'm proud to support
Independence the next World premiere
comes from a game award-winning Studio
up in my native Canada ah Canadians are
now an idiot
all right anime
no for me dog
and the creators was the last
oh that's big that's big oh wait wait
what yeah
he can't have been hating now I had to
look back for the greatest let's watch
hey
what I cheated the animals
we got 457 people in that chat man hit
that like button man do us a favor get
us to the algorithm so more people can
hear Kings nonsense weekly
tell a friend tell a friend you know
what I almost did Carl but I just didn't
have time because I could have made it
to where when I pushed the button for us
to get a point the person that got the
point would say something
I'm getting worried vibes from this yeah
more like an old school kind of
so it said
yo they stupid
yeah messy a little messy when y'all get
them High Fidelity graphics
Sunday is going to be crazy
what a show
we got the video game
to recap we have uh the FTC nonsense we
have the Rays in the games nonsense I
gotta guess
we have a guest we have a guest
I'm not gonna tell you because you know
you always leak it yeah
wow I'm sorry that looks like that got
to come out in two years
like I I don't understand
you clean
oh oh I know this game
you wander the dry dirty streets of
civilization
this is lumens
nothing gets caught more excited than
Acquisitions and ends like
it's like moving is going on although
he's always happy with us we can give
him that so it's the tits that in the
building
you know they didn't say in the building
yo you stupid
what's going on civilizations unrest
you do all of these things in my dreams
I am
terrified of what happened why are you
all over again
[Music]
okay about my instinct was right
okay nice notes for open world survival
mode
I'm gonna give it a shot
spent eighty dollars for that uh I need
to see them all I need to see more not
gonna be negative
Awakening tonight all the major gaming
platforms are offering special discounts
and offers on TJ nominees you can check
out the game awards sale across steam
Xbox PlayStation epic stories
arcade writing is the best
steam Xbox and for the first time
PlayStation
to play ball
Josh that's what's this
before you came Final Fantasy oh nope or
spoken fear of this Hunters whereas
people will say eventually
but now now
because people had issues with the
dialogue there's four next
this game will be coming to Xbox in 2025
even though the dialogue people had
issue I've been rocking this game for a
minute I'm playing this on PC and then
I'll wait two years of played on it well
it looks interesting to you oh yeah yeah
so you really get rid of your Xbox or
your PlayStation creative looking what's
going on oh
smooth you really getting rid of your
PlayStation is not for you absolutely
it's just I played Final Fantasy 15 I
know this so hold up hold up I'm gonna
put I'm gonna put in the chat do you
guys honestly think smooth really going
to sell his PlayStation
my PS5
a demo now oh the demos Productions
[Applause]
let's go yes it's like I already got it
still so I'm gonna use it
yo the second app for the second half
yeah
it does kind of look a little suspect
they ain't showing a game but they're
going to show this like
um
we're getting the TV off
[Music]
any controller with Xbox yeah yeah our
Indie Partners bring a whole world of
fun they spend New Life into familiar
faces
dance battles front and center challenge
us to aim higher and create Secrets
destined to be discovered all before the
eyes of a captive audience so here's a
big thanks we can't wait to see where
the fun takes you next
nice
damn this game's still alive holy [ __ ]
pubg from now oh my God
I'm not seeing it on the demo on the
store I see the season demo thirsty
students Bramble I don't see Game of
Wars demo for football
usually it's not there like the second
one yeah coilovers
get you an impact got that unique art
style
why is both horsepower enough
procrastinating let's go you want to
come over for tea
yeah it's not up
yeah it'll be up in a little bit I'm
pretty sure demos will come up until
like an hour after the announcement or
something there's no such thing as Pure
Freedom in this world even the wind
cannot be better
oh February yeah it's not there yet okay
so why do they say it's available there
here comes the couch
The Wind Rises
I will say this is a better TGA than
last year it's just yeah oh my God Al
Pacino okay yeah
[Music]
resigned from gaming or something like
that and that was the spinal speech like
no no
stupid bag
yeah you shouldn't impact
[Music]
this is still against it yep
food break okay stay back yeah
he's missing
welcome back to the game awards that was
look against an impact now in the middle
of its third year and a double nominee
tonight and a sneak peek at Yahoo in
upcoming character to join its growing
roster next is something truly truly
special tonight all of us together get
to experience the global announcement of
the next game from one of our industry's
most Visionary game studios
get ready please enjoy doing that Tech
again you're doing that attacking yeah
I'm getting food
oh dude you're on PS5 is going to be
trash
[Music]
all is oh oh that's ready too
Dexter edit too let's go
babies let's get it let's get the BB
oh my God put the BB and the beep be in
the chat you
so let love
where your babies is at six God I will
just never fell asleep to a video game
until I played destruction
let's get off FedEx horn
[Music]
s
[Music]
and this is unexpected not really I mean
I feel like ahead right
[Music]
well desk training when did destroying
come out chat look that up for me 2019
September or November 2018. that's about
right probably 20 24.
yeah this is not coming out no it is
coming out next year probably
wait a minute
they said babysitting some of them
is it going to be another empty wall
no it's still going
I don't care where you all say I'll hate
on this game forever it's so boring
I have no clue what I just watched I'm
gonna be real with you guys
the BB you about to have no clue where
you're about to play too
Brandon he has no shock too it's the
second stranding game guys
don't worry okay it's it's okay it's
gone all right what I missed nothing
good thank you no one should have to
suffer no that that's relevant like
oh
my God why is he always naked
oh what is this
not even the actors are gonna know
what's up
yo who am I kidding PlayStation guys
leave the [ __ ] up
did you play Just trading yeah I do
did you like it
not my cup of tea but it's different
yeah
it's not gonna help the gameplay
have you played it
yeah
a private that's a big that's a big
thing like we gotta okay no no no no you
can't call me a fan boy
what the hell man
all right I I'm not gonna cap look at my
steam page I got let me check
I got 12 hours in death stranding
I'm just saying he's also making some
for Xbox and I still don't care I I I I
get you but that's still a big thing for
them
join me in welcoming back to the game
awards oh God Kojima gonna talk for like
40 minutes
[Applause]
[Applause]
good
hockey great to see you uh well Mr
kojimo it's been three years you're on
this stage with us in 2019 where you won
best game Direction uh DS2 has been
announced uh what can you tell us how is
it going to be different than DS1 is
I can't really be specific right now but
you just seen the trailer and I put a
lot of things inside so I want you guys
to talk about it and find Details in it
shut up I know we have some of the cash
from the game with us here hello are you
guys with us here
um Joy is here as well we heard him
there hello Troy Norman we're so excited
about this collaboration you have with
an amazing cast I wanted to ask you the
story of this game how is the pandemic
and what we've been through how has that
impacted your storytelling and the theme
of this game
well I had the story written before the
pandemic but after experiment
experiencing the pandemic I just rewrote
the whole thing uh the story from
scratch what
I also didn't want to predict any more
future so I rewrite
all right Mr kojiba it's always such a
pleasure having you here I wanted to ask
generally what's next for you as a
Creator I know we have our fun
podcasts
well yes I'm doing the DS2 right now and
also one other title that's completely
new I'm kind of experimenting at the
moment and also other visual projects
I'm still working on so I'll hope to
reveal it soon I said well you're always
very prolific
Adele Kojima everyone
[Applause]
well next we have another Global game
announcement we're proud to announce a
new game for any new world for a new
independent Studio ascendant Studio this
is even a good game it's making story
driven FPS games like Dead Space
label behind last year's Game of the
Year winner just because you don't like
the context
set within a new original World here is
your first Glimpse you know yeah coming
in let's go
oh that monster hunter game I think
well you said it was a new world I love
how they say EA original dangerous for
you here I mean you got to give the a
shredder your man they do help out some
of your family
I like that movie I was one of the only
people that did all you are is angry
you help us win this
I'll know you're ready
I like it I like it I love how they're
like this ain't the game
is not the game they literally just said
that that was cut off
Mortals of Heaven
23 and that wasn't game
you mean 2024 they go push that back
[Applause]
he's an actor who recently performed in
midnight mass and Ghostbusters Spirits
Unleashed here's the next award please
welcome Rahul Kohli rahu
as an actor I'm drawn towards stories
but I think that's true of all of us
especially those who pick up the
controller narrative is a slippery thing
because there's no single way to tell a
story the beginning middle and end may
not even happen in that order and for
each of us there may be different
outcomes all together but to be truly
invested in a game's story step away and
feel as if you've lived another life
these are the nominees for the best
narrative Colt Eastwood
we all said God Awards
I just hope Christopher will come up
there and collect this reward
s
remember remember
do not do not give it away do not give
it away
God of War Ragnarok we all got a point
okay
Let The Sweep begin
where's Chris George why are you taking
it days like that um Chris is on timeout
and uh
[Music]
[Music]
more soft heels man Sony got the bag
yeah you know Sony gave out the bag
[Applause]
there are so many people a lot of them
over there who should be on this stage
with me right now
um
so much goes into the television story
in a video hey welcome to life story
part two writers animators
technical designers artists
programmers audio music 2018 was like
that
oh my gosh what's on the page
just finished it yo it's smooth
everything that we did
um I'm just I'm honored to accept this
on their behalf
um I want to thank uh Playstation uh
Skype I'm right here Herman
SMS
when we all had to shift to work from
home that's incredible and they're still
supporting us now
um this man saying she's working from
home a bad thing I'm just kidding I'm
grateful to be here I'm grateful for
your support from home that's a bad
thing they just had an adjustment I'm
sure that was respect
um I also want to thank obviously you me
uh
Corey and our captain Eric Williams
you know what they're going to do Carl
they're going to give like five out of
time
after Corey stepped aside for this one
rich and I couldn't have asked for a
more support when elderly baby and uh
I'm gonna keep my camera up because I
have a feeling I'm gonna have to take a
picture of it sorry uh I also want to
thank our families who went from having
to see us in the morning and at night to
having to see us all day every week
that's that's a burden I wouldn't wish
for on anyone putting the music back on
his wife Suzanne James
it's a wrap you gotta go it's like
there's the hook that's okay it's Gotta
Wear Ragnarok today is December 8th so
notice you heard the music and he closed
like right after a year game play of
Texas
let's go
let's not go
I want to hit him I want to hear no sled
I want to hear everything
[Music]
what's going on
what is this who is that is that Jen
how does that attack him okay
oh it's Jordan
it's really crazy
[Music]
that's huge people know what to tell you
that is
oh let's go yeah Street Fighter 6 took a
back seat I suggestion
literally make it I spent two thousand
dollars
first time you recognize more Awards
buddy I'm ready here are the nominees
for best art Direction
and stray
what did we pick game awards too
Eldon ring art Direction
wow here are the nominees for best VR AR
game after the fight song
and the game award goes to
nobody wants
the nominees for best Sims strategy game
spice Wars Mario and rabbits Sparks of
Hope total war war we all picked Mario
two-point campus and Victoria three the
game award this year goes to Mario oh we
all got a point congratulations I'm not
getting any points the best community
support presented by Discord
Destiny two yeah
we all pick no man's sky but Fortnight
he picked fortnite and the game award
goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not high right some everyone else
saw that she's got a walking tree 's on
the brink
the magical network of portals has
collapsed hey look that's what's Halo
bro
you can see
well best community
you must gather your wins surprise
like that
solving King wanted to pick bone lab but
they put they picked Among Us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
s from Verizon you'll get a free
controller QR code below to pick up an
Xbox 360 no I'm talking about Instagram
at average underscore Jonas for more
appealing because oh he's going to keep
doing whatever you want yeah
same commercial okay yeah
yeah they gotta beat you over the head
with games they're getting them Game
Pass ads in huh
I think starfield's gonna show up then
what's interesting is Jedi's already
been shown so they're not ending we
won't have a goalie yeah we'll do that
hit me up next week
would have been a good game to end it
with but they already showed us to lose
ourselves in news stories
that's interesting
showing up just just to sit there and
watch all these bums
y
and that's why people people like at the
beginning once again did they really
just show a bunch of unreleased games
for Game Pass ads
yep
with everything in front of us hey you
could play this game if we would ever
release it to explore
fooling yet to be felt like you watch
them
all right to watch whoa get ready
have fun
thinking true Phil and Sarah to the
table
where is Phil Spencer getting one of
quitting vaping once I get a couple days
under myself
I thought it was helping but then I
quickly realized that it just made me
feel way worse the biggest advice I
would give to anyone out there that is
currently thinking about quitting vaping
nicotine is don't be afraid to talk to
someone and if you don't have a
supporting you can be there for you
don't feel alone don't please don't
forget about the Samsung 990 Pro Series
let's go reading speeds are 40 quicker
than before and writing speeds are 55
faster I need to spend five years
[Music]
the 990 Pro's nickel coating yeah
we're getting dragged out here
it was the art direction that gave him
another point
oh you're shooting from tonight until
the end of December you can get an
exclusive chance for ten percent off the
Samsung 99
experience the promo code is 990 Pro TGA
22. all right our next presenters are
absolute Legends they attended the very
first game awards where we honored them
with our first everybody Legends they
founded Sierra online they brought us
Half-Life king's quest and hundreds of
beetles and this show my career in
gaming would not exist without them
their latest game they're back making
games which we're excited about is
called Colossal Cave and it launches
January 19th everyone please join me in
welcoming to the game awards Ken and
Roberta Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
when we first started making games many
many years ago we knew the potential was
there to achieve almost anything even to
change the world
we're honored to be back here
change the way people think gains for
impact
Saul King and me said citizen Incognito
ACG said that does fall impact
let me go with the Memoir bloops that's
the only one I actually played yeah
it was gonna be terrible and I played it
and it was probably one of the best
games I've played this year
yeah it's hard not to drift into the
past
me and King need this mean King need
this and the game award for games for
impact actually I hope it's with you
guys because because I want I want solve
to lose
yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
they deserve that
I'm so proud of it
foreign
I'm so proud
get it girl wow get it girl
thank you so much
um I had notes but um I forgot
everything
advice
the game we made together with this
amazing team was like eight years in the
making we really hoped to create
um you know an experience that was
unique
narrative that was intense grounded and
also communal because as dustful's yes
and approachable
um and so the story of azdas folzak
presents you know
floats characters uh normal people that
struggle with their real life issues and
are thrown in super intense pressure
cooker situations the hotel was crazy we
hope that players would feel empathy for
them would
hopefully
the game the game would have never lived
without Game Pass I have to put that out
oh dude me and my wife we would fight
each other
and then the game rates you the type of
person you are based on your decisions
I got the one that he's kind of a
heartless
I love you infinity forever
what's the song started playing I've
been telling you Hey listen
to the very end cheers
is ready to share just when you're going
to be able to join the party Divinity
original sin develop
ment
we must all cure ourselves of the entire
Cult of the absolute
[Music]
all the way here from Boulder's games
it is Undead where you at you about to
go crazy loads of gaming.net's about to
go crazy I [ __ ] love this game
they've been working on this game let's
try to find a solution too I know but it
looks like it's like
oh we got we got representation I'm good
[Music]
dude
Valerian Studios can make a freaking
game
interesting they make the best RPGs
right now turn-based RPGs they make the
best is what it is
this this might be the one notice the
engine I like the city the original sin
looks amazing like this yes
[Music]
dude I I hated top down game
I get me into like varic from Dragon Age
huh
foreign
looks amazing I'm here with Joe MADD
legendary comic artist and CEO of
Airsoft Syndicate Joe tonight you have a
new title to announce right we do a few
months ago uh we announced
okay okay
just a huge success over the last 10
years and now we're going to leverage
and I'm listening on our new game which
is a character based on how you do it
action RPG set in a brand new fantasy
world and we're super excited and uh I
think there's a little bit more you got
another partner to talk about too we do
another partner uh has come on board uh
actually support us and help us reach
even more players around the world and
uh you'll be able to play it a lot
sooner than you might we gotta actually
get a trailer well let's take a look at
these kids
just post you into your subscription to
PlayStation
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I ain't playing it
what if this is not exclusive what if
you could play it all right
did they partner replacing Shenanigans
is not available
I respect yourself
sharpened many blades played a few
tricks
I mean you see Microsoft's statement
today they ripped the claws off yeah
it's definitely nothing looks like it's
going to court they fight
I hope it succeeds
so this is your favorite is your joint
no this is a part of games with digital
extreme set it's kind of like it looks
like a World of Warcraft yeah give me
Warcraft energy with a little OverWatch
[Music]
could be like a Souls type of thing who
knows stop telling us off he winning he
don't need to know
yeah PlayStation steam exclusive of
course
is it live service player yes
live service the time has come yo
Microsoft
what's this yeah this is um
uh Fire Emblem I'm definitely oh engaged
okay oh a gay expansion pack okay
[Music]
[Music]
that chick was like one of the
characters
these are good games
um I'll take your word for it but don't
try it Jesse is not convinced
join me now are Genova Chen from that
game company creators of Journey and sky
and singer-songwriter Aurora welcome to
the game awards and we're right after
the show tonight you are going to be
performing a virtual and free concert in
sky is that right yes and I'm so excited
I'm sorry about my voice it's so [ __ ]
up it's saying karaoke last night sorry
about my voice
you'll be perfect in the virtual yeah
right but tonight it will be very good
yes so tell us this is an amazing
collaboration uh working with Genova and
the team why did you want to dance
mostly because
working on Sky children of flight and
Genova it's just the best kind of people
and it feels like this this project is
so full of love and and light and
understandment
um of The Outsiders and finding a way to
make us feel home and connected it's
very it's just pure yeah I got to
experience it last week and it really is
very moving I think
[Music]
yeah I mean historically we always want
to push the boundary I know it's not
hard games
I mean we've already said but with since
yeah
say Jackson they can't hear you
hurry up
no they can't hear him
this week and I'm used to doing
everything
so maybe we can just look at a trailer
and hopefully that will help to explain
amazing
flower journey to Skye hey Journey was a
good game continuing to push the
boundary of video games emotional
potential
wow did you hear that did you hear that
flame I mean that's how you get back to
a game like a concert uh I mean I'm
still gonna play the other one I'm just
not gonna say that I like it though
that is so wild on this [ __ ] right now
I cannot repeat what you're doing in the
chat right now we haven't found this in
any video games
and after 18 months of experimentation
and development we feel it now
we made this concert
with your friends and loved ones you can
download yeah
join us for this groundbreaking moment
shared by millions of players worldwide
[Music]
relax check that out it's really really
special all right this year we partnered
with GrubHub to get your food delivered
for the game awards
you'll receive a free vehicle wrap on
orders of twelve dollars
and complete other challenges terms
and conditions apply boys
controller
yo anybody else
the new season comes out
this week
[Music]
is
a problem
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
uh oh music section time for food no
this is when Microsoft comes and steals
the show oh there's hellblade what if
there does hellblade with the release
date right now again and what if she
come out what if they do to live action
performance
here we go Ferguson
100 Diablo guaranteed it's not feeling
diablo-ish but it's a music video that
definitely looks like Ferguson
[Music]
no I mean she probably did stuff with
Jay-Z but [ __ ] introduction
[Music]
keep it together keep it together
oh she dated that one rapper the white
rapper
yeah she dated G-Eazy okay
suicide kicks relax that's not Advanced
GG she was drinking
give away
the more that you have the most students
what game is this
[Applause]
oh here we go you know the chat want to
play that game called you know the chat
want to play that game real bad yeah I'm
doing hey we had to play that game
below
game of the year they got Gregorian
chants game
[Music]
you got Gregorian chants
I wish I could step on lava like that
and lose all your feet skin that's
disgusting gotta have that melanin to
survive then
you didn't just say that
is very lordly
oh this look oh this is iron Lord
approved
kick ass trust me
I mean I'm mad they went away from the
art style Diablo's three whatever
[Music]
and His holy name
mm-hmm
God stop being messy this is what scooty
so do you scared yeah yeah I'm messy
you're not wrong though
yo if they don't show the platforms this
are going to XBox exclusive guaranteed
that younger spit
oh I'm gonna play the hell out of this
game
crazy
this looked Wild
did you ever play Diablo 3 yes
oh
that was my first Diablo this is so good
I'm I'm bummed out babe
oh [ __ ] you're going to hell on this one
six six six
Jude oh they push that back plenty of
time so they can make that exclusive he
said try to push it out
Halsey are just getting started on their
collaboration leading up to the launch
more from Diablo and Halsey next year
but wasn't that incredible thank you so
much oh wow she is in the game we'd like
to recognize some of the other winners
tonight
holy world
series
OverWatch too Splatoon
and the game award goes to
all right
nobody King wanted to fix platoon
God of War Ragnarok Gran Turismo 7. we
also got Awards the Call of Duty and
this
is
the nominees for content creator of the
year
I'm here for chaos Rebellion let's go
the billion out the billion got a winner
they got it with this and the game award
goes to Rebellion does content
surprise
here are the nominees for most and we
vote for this one Legend of Zelda Zelda
when you said you said Starfield
[Music]
Resident Evil 4
come on
and the legend of something
[Applause]
maybe a fan favorite oh my God he the
biased dick before he said it the legend
of zero I said it wow
congratulations to all our winners
Another World premiere Microsoft said
look man we don't win a single award we
out I'm getting smashed up damn
oh Horizon
this woman man like who likes this game
I don't know anyone that likes this game
yeah
amazing though did you play don't look
good
no I'm basketball okay so I'm asking you
did you
so you sound like you're speaking from
experience
I just wanted to clarify that
I see what you did though yeah don't
just be a messy back
it's kind of sad Microsoft promote game
passing uh Playstation promoting games
hmm
oh that is so messed up the burning
shores of all these look at the burning
Shores
oh they ripping down to Hollywood side
you Maniacs you really do oh April
[Applause]
burning Shores will see Eloy for not
impressed pursue a Sinister threat in
the Untamed Wilds of Los Angeles and yes
even the Hollywood Sign have you guys
noticed that that game has wow please
welcome the cast of The Last of Us yeah
let's go are we getting the full Saudi
blowout today baby
let's go
I can't wait to watch it
Pedro
just just real quick I I know that I
told you guys this backstage but just in
front of everybody else I want to let
you know
we've seen the show and I hope you've
seen the show
we just love you as Joel oh thank you
thank you big fans big fan so you know
we are big fans of you two as well as
Joel and Ellie all right
um so should we do this all together
let's do it okay okay
we're here to present the award for best
action game
have action and these are the ones that
truly kicked out yes this kicks ass we
all said uh Seafood off
I can't make ground keep picking up
okay I'll go and say another three
because that's the only one that I've
actually played so
I think Jason said Call of Duty five
times
it is it is
what if Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles I
know yo Maddie will go crazy all right
perfect
game award for the best action games
[Applause]
oh no
yeah
that'll be Seafood
no get up there please King wanted to
pick
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles all right
this is pretty awesome
um on behalf of the development teams at
Platinum everybody we happy except that
voice actor tirelessly on bringing
Bayonetta to life for the third time
thank you Grace you don't get no pieces
right now so this is for you folks
congratulations let me stop
I think you all know this but no one
does
action games and over-the-top action
games like Platinum Games and as you saw
they're already hard at work on their
next project so they asked me to say a
few words on their behalf oh Super Chat
oh Lord with our long history I
appreciate it this is the Sony Awards to
be awarded the music's already playing
the music's are so delighted to have
been able to reveal for the game awards
today we'd like to thank everyone who
helped us bring the game to life and of
course the fans of the series with the
characters just as important as the many
players you know this uh in the
background to the many players is
gameplay
you know how I listen to music with no
words
thank you very much screen what up
wow congratulations yeah where's skill
bound at on stage and it don't steal
congratulations to PG Nintendo
first let's head to Japan for a special
I won't say the pacing is better
I think this is a good show it is
oh
um
foreign
so
[Laughter]
in the mix of gameplay
do you remember do you remember
what our world was before
I like the art oh it sounds cool before
the sun directs okay what are you
looking at
what flame this is you you're looking at
Amazon's future flop
that actually don't look well let's see
let me see how this a little more
actually it does look pretty good
May cop it actually although the one
study I want to hear from is the one
that made Scarlet Nexus because I know
there is yes
it's on Luna for a year before it gets
to console
what they said
oh yeah okay never mind
they started us down here went all the
way up
look cool it does look
I don't know you know what that reminds
me of uh what was that game that came on
the game pass that was the Japanese game
yep it's bad now I'm cold Scarlet Nexus
a little bit yeah it's called Nexus it
looks like
yeah it looks a little bit like this a
little bit more I'm so glad I'm eating
right now oh damn
like 100 hours
your future I stay away from GameStop
okay so it actually is called Blue
protocol I think that was the Studio's
name common 2023
Amazon games the PS5 Xbox series X and S
ucks which studio did make Scarlet Nexus
it was bad right now
okay
[Music]
well it looks like Dustin at the
beginning
foreign
[Music]
that was messy that's a messy thing you
said all day
okay so I could just expect that one
okay
I can [ __ ] with this game
remnants in the ashes or something yeah
I think now
it looks like bloodborne
it looks like so many different things
like I looked at like seven different
games
Remnant two
yeah
cyber this ain't working
um
no splash damage
loading memory chord now
wait
no by 10 cents
oh what's this like the Reapers it's
like a Reaper
[Music]
but still they're very look very
reaper-ish
all right this gear is inspired
[Music]
Transformers
it looks actually so far decent so far
[Applause]
[Music]
mature
Sega
hey I love anything in World War II
persona 6.
6
[Applause]
this was going to be Call of Duty on
switch
yo
yo that was crazy no this is what Call
of Duty would look like if they didn't
give that 10-year deal
oh no that's the version you don't play
the game it's just a movie
[Laughter]
even more
yo
that's that's oh this game's already out
you're messy oh oh team shut up oh
Facebook in here oh okay then you put
your hands together
[Laughter]
in the chat they said listen listen man
get your hands ready
hmm
wait hold on this looks open inside the
contract we got Skyrim
we got Skyrim videos
put the clutch up
Wow Let's Go
it looks like this on The
Meadows it's a game
who knows
thank you
yeah I'm big
let's go oh that looks great this guy
look crazy
right
this looks crazy Quest gang let's go
just give me motions though let's go
exclusive
wow
that actually looks pretty cool not
gonna lie we stopped the show Skyrim
that's it because the season
oh God
don't let me get that four guys
there were presents on offer in the snow
and the ice
that was resourceful enough to complete
gift grab they stumbled into the
Nutcracker thus looking Fab foot is the
season for fun and frolics for all even
SpongeBob shut up SpongeBob
guys for a while
he's the voice of toad in the upcoming
Super Mario Brothers movie please
welcome Keegan Michael Key oh Michael
Keith Chris proud We all here
he's told
what's happening
I like his anything he's getting old
we can all be here and having such a
good time and celebrating tonight right
yes
okay now all right there is something
that I would like to address and uh if
you guessed that it is well something
about
um Toad's head
A.A Ron uh
saying that it's a hat and and you know
what it's not a hat it's a cap
you see because the cap is that top part
of the mushroom houses the spores and
everything and also I could be funny
because he's a hilarious guy like is it
another word for hat he's just bombing
I see how that okay I just right now saw
how that could be confusing
um
wow
okay whether you call it a cap or a hat
or a capat I'm good with all of it
because it's just parts of Toad's
awesomeness so now please enjoy this
clipart over here
friends in a sneak preview of their
super awesome Journey
mmm
I will not speak
[Music]
there you go excuse me
excuse me everybody
this guy's brother is going to die
imminently out of the way please he's
trying to clear a path that's all I'm
doing man my kids are going to love this
movie
I'm gonna watch this
was that Angry Birds
[Music]
you just have to blow into it and up we
go
[Music]
they got the music
[Music]
I like how they're kind of putting the
platforming thing a little bit
[Music]
okay so these bricks are just floating
here just popping this pipe and we're on
our way it's the only way to fly man
they got the music oh wow love these
pipes
[Music]
and Nintendo just likes to print money
here we go this is going to sell like
hot cakes uh they're going straight to
the bank
you are right they are pretty money did
you hear the did you hear the sound from
the tube that's them actually hurt them
up
that looks absolutely so amazing
oh my God
Muppets Mayhem from the movie plugin
gamers are like five
gotta get that young demographic
they're literally all
awesome
what message are we sending to the kids
what's going on here
[Music]
over the place
yeah I I guess you could we'll talk to
hideo at the after party see what we can
make happen uh but all right well hello
Crossing
I think that one's taken the Nintendo
lawyer doesn't have some issues with
that but anyways animal it's great to
have you yeah should we maybe give out
an award now fall asleep again smooth oh
yeah no sick no sick I'm not sleeping
okay
heads
are you going off on Twitter and music a
little bit now
right so
everyone pick metal
but ACG he picked a topic everyone
picked metal
housing a thing yeah yeah
I'm gonna pick whatever Play-Doh
hey you notice ACG started to catch up
oh yeah
oh where's open open up okay animal okay
and the game Award for best score and
music goes to
God of War
and yeah
[Applause]
get ready
get ready
how y'all feeling
[Applause]
Corey when you told me this story
part of my life ever since
I'm feeling confident
all the musicians
fiddle players and and hardinger Fiddle
and nickel harp all these wonderful
um musicians from around the world also
lent there
could have just went to sleep
performances yeah I gotta celebrate the
glory that is
Simplicity
I wanted to write him just a few notes
and I got to write
um [Music]
and if I'd only wrote that I I I I feel
like the story is you know actually
bring up Christian a lot more thank you
so much everybody listens to the world
to me thank you the whole cast we go get
the whole team up here
it is kind of funny they put that music
in to tell people yo yeah the guys
funny Christopher talked for like five
minutes with that all they didn't
implement the program entertainment
we got
I don't know what now
I remember liking it I'm following
why I'm a fanboy why are you mad at me
I'm just celebrating the greatness of
God whoa
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a God of War family right
me and master say some strange things
[Music]
it's a strange things because they make
light of the Stream
[Music]
wait is this that freaking walking thank
you Leo for defending me
thank you
they don't make stuff like this though
[Laughter]
cosmetics
foreign
[Music]
no that's not Kiki Palmer dude
I literally thought it was Kiki
[Music]
we all found a case move moment okay
respect
was back that rise up I didn't
understand
you here for kid you ain't here for me
um
[Music]
okay what if we'll see what this game
was okay whatever I'm not just uh oh
wait never mind okay I'm shutting up now
let's go um is this actually a game here
[Music]
oh my God okay okay
okay they're actually making a game game
good job oh God you finally didn't oh
wait another one
oh oh
it's Warhammer Defenders of mankind yes
against the Horus the dwell in the
Darkness
I'm gonna go say goodnight to my kids
really quick
Attica
we are the Angels against
blisters
might not show anything
we are literally like 15 minutes away
from being finished and they haven't
checked yeah I'd like to have a problem
[Applause]
World premiere
what's going on thumbs up with this
Power Rangers
I'm gonna say it
better not be doing again we've already
seen this damn thing
what does this move
I'm not saying
there's like another Doom game of sort
of Doom game that was supposed to come
out I'm wondering if this just like CGI
of it or something
foreign
interesting
are you simulated
oh my god oh man
I don't have to say yeah they could have
just showed this stuff
okay so it's like a little building the
Builder yeah yeah you mix stuff
for the upcoming beta the game launches
April 4th 2023. all week twitch is
celebrating what games week recognizing
all the games from gaming history that
never got their proper dude like EA's
overblood which was the most played game
this week as a game from 1997. which
game Saw the biggest increase in
viewership over the week according to a
twitch Twitter poll the winner was
Katamari all right we've got much more
game awards ahead more World premieres
including an update on Final Fantasy 16
and of course the game of the year
presented by last year's winner Joseph
Ferris who knows what he's going to say
hopefully it's short all right we'll be
right back I'll see you us here we're
gonna care about that now huh Jeff
here's to colorful competition here's to
inking Turf together here's to every
friend every rival every splat Here's to
You Splatoon 3 community
I'm doing good
I'm here for these Awards I'm having a
good old time yeah
[Applause]
do you have any idea of black polish
moving get it
dodging
pause
um
[Music]
I tried playing this game some years
back and I'm like yeah
even their fans will murder you if they
have their jobs
blood Bowl the video game of fantasy
football interesting
and she's in danger you will find out
have to enter at all costs now or The
Witcher
hey this is the next gen version new
content inspired by the Netflix series
too
63 Ray tracing and cannot be killed can
it
December 14th y'all
next week did I just really just missed
the Witcher oh yeah all right and here's
your fortnight
ah this game is still alive
oh no
um
[Music]
in the back
welcome back
coming to the stage
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
the new crash new
crashes in the building let's go
get ready for an epic reveal in three
two one crash
zero
negative one
negative is too funny
where's my crew
hold on a second
what happened yeah you were supposed to
meet up here but I said by yourself is
now made it appearance
was a fruitless plant
the old silent treatment that's fine
more Wampa for me wherever it is y'all I
want a lump of fruit now roll the
trailer grandma
[Music]
yeah
Microsoft's still losing bro how are you
gonna buy Activision and lose
of course they can't mention that stuff
to The Regulators
whatever
yeah like a bunch of salty
[Music]
in the pursuit of fruit
thank you
a real game
oh it's team Rumble oh okay so okay okay
you know I was being a bit salty or
whatever
now please welcome two outstanding
contacts
here are fusley and Valkyrie
while gaming continues to rapidly evolve
every year if there's one category that
seems to advance the fastest and
furthest it's Innovation and
accessibility each year designers
impress and inspired
audience to play their games
hear the Game Awards nominees for
Innovation Innovation accessibility but
we got
someone's gotta have funky Islands back
and the game award for Innovation and
accessibility goes to God of War
God award dominance continues there is
no sound
there is no it just got crazy
accessibility right though you've
customized almost everything of that
thank you for everyone we are absolutely
humbled and stop it in this journey
along the way
this is important for the players it's
you all you who play the games that are
really the ones that deserve this award
no we don't everyone who was on the team
at SMS we are truly honored to be with
you thank you so much Eric and you and
me for supporting us John and Jason for
being there to make these accessibility
features happen Katie Sam and Zach my
closest cohorts when we were trying to
make these features and all of our team
in the QA and accessibility research
teams the UI ux team and everyone who
made it possible uh I can't thank you
enough and I think that the players
themselves are the ones that are going
to benefit the most this is a race that
no matter who wins the player is the
real winner so let's go out there and
make all games have no limits thank you
but the music started playing at the end
[Applause]
it's a really unique way of saying get
the hell off my face
the boys of the falling
yeah second one
is
life
well we'll be right back
probably because I hate the game
we did best audio foreign
yes I believe so I think they got away
with these all those characters
from what lies we didn't do best game
Direction
did we do best performance the Shadows
yeah it wasn't that God Awards yeah
Elder ring won anything
yes no that's art Direction art
Direction yes that was a surprise yes
of all these Awards
no no fans has best fighting been
announced he's been winning yeah yes all
the awards I don't understand how on
some of these this fighting was
announced yeah Multiverse Multiverse
of course nobody ain't trying to do
these stage two fights Super Chat Lord
Meyerhoff I can't pronounce your
currency Xbox is done not even a single
game trailer
[Applause]
and now from 505 games
crime game Crime Boss Rocket City please
welcome mobile apps and the boss himself
Michael Mister Michael Madsen I thought
they had Conor McGregor
[Music]
the trailer you're about to watch
you see this trailer here well
a little different than the rest of
these trailers you're seeing tonight
this one's a little bit dangerous
so the boss wanted to come out here you
know make sure you don't hurt yourself
sometime during the next 60 Seconds
what did I just come back to what a
crowd
came back oh my God what a night
ow um
listen I uh
I've had some wild times uh I've been
involved in some crazy things in my life
I even made a picture with Mr Al Pacino
[Music]
Donnie Brasco if you haven't seen it you
should look it up God damn it so
anyway I have to say being the Crime
Boss of rock Cave City
now that's a lot of fun
and uh we've got an amazing cast with us
these two handsome guys with me
and uh anyway
enjoy the debut trailer for Crime Boss
Rocky City coming March 28th 2023 so
let's roll it roll it oh burning Shores
is uh the burning Shores DLC for
Horizons only PS5 okay hold on I love it
oh wait is that I love him so the DLC is
not uh that's what the Paris is saying
okay
oh that's funny
they finally believe in Generations
Johnny Trail Danny Trejo let's go
daddy Glover
Betty Glover
oh
yo Fred what yo you stupid he said I see
that the F sharp North stage tonight I'm
done
Chuck Norris
that's right Chuck Norris all right and
now we are happy to announce more
winners here at the game awards based on
votes from our jury and all right get
ready nominees for best role playing
games
congratulations
here are the nominees for players voice
are 100 more fan voted category
how many Sonic Frontiers yeah but he's
the players vote this it's the place God
of War right
and once we took out all the bot boats
the game award goes to again
I think I got C4 this was Seafood stray
aggressive and the game award goes to
straight Oh yeah
double winner tonight oh wow oh yeah
I jumped out the window here I jumped
out the window here I think Rising
forbidden West stray and tunic and the
game
but
here are the nominees for best ongoing
games Apex Legends Final Fantasy 14.
and the game award goes to Final Fantasy
they saw what that was
no one won that one okay good
another thing here
call duty
yeah
Call of Duty they'll never win oh raids
[Music]
raids baby yo
yo what's up
from digital streams they set me the
stuff oh that look fine
yeah
oh no they just sent me the stuff for
wayfinder so now I gotta go back and
make a better article so let's see what
it leads there's three or four players
dancing
oh it's gonna be four players I think
it's three
oh it's three yeah you're right it's
three because it's part of DMZ
great episode episodes on the way what
the hell is
hell
when they dropped when it drops when it
dropped December there's only two
there's only two left oh man if I don't
win game but I think oh
there's no way you can win no way
yes for game of the here he saw
new Xbox Discord
get it
if this is Xbox big announcement
oh this is their big announcement
man they really pushing a gosh dang
Doritos I came in dead ass last Doritos
triangle Island created
normally I'm the one that's left
no because I try I try to give Horizons
of the doubt they didn't win one Awards
the developers of Marvel snaps
watch them give them the last two Awards
I like that Horizon forbidden rewards
throughout the good one here's a clip of
hero
no it was bad I just made these for fun
are we really advertising mobile games
now
yes because that's I know where the
money is at this point
[Music]
thank you
I will give up gaming before I go to
mobile
get ready
that game is huge and I'm almost there
I just can't play it I get too addictive
card games I was like nope I put a band
on myself no more I came over again
[Music]
we have 900 people in here right now how
are you feeling yo Carl can you hit the
fast forward button my name is Michael
my therapist who I adore when we learned
that I had add it gave me a whole new
perspective on my life and gave me a lot
of answers that I didn't even know that
I was seeking problems with the
lightsaber and everything
it hurts honey it hurts
I knew that I wanted to help Usher that
experience for folks that really needed
it thank you thank you for the love per
usual for the best per usual if I am
inspiring other people to be authentic
if I'm inspiring people to seek mental
health then I definitely feel good about
that
December just like Santa give it up for
Reggie
okay here we go our boy Reggie
somebody you got to move
yes
I love Reggie so this year me too I'm
here to present the best game Direction
category
and it's a particularly exciting award
especially in our industry
games are constantly pushing the
boundaries of creativity
Innovation and artistry
and to be nominated
you need to have created an experience
that is incredibly special to the
players
to the teams represented Behind these
titles you have my utmost respect
here are the nominees for the best game
Direction
best game Direction
[Music]
you're getting closer and close to the
big joint right yeah there's only two
lessons yes
learn to style
is dying I'm running out of time
in 5B take one he shot twenty thousand
girls you picked you
watch straight one game
and the game for best game Direction
goes to
Alden ring
is this the sign of the change
is this this one this would be song
prediction Dom called it so I'll save I
need that
oh my god
oh solve this say that his prediction
was that God of War would clean up
everything
and unlike 2018 elderly would win but
when when remember in 2018 right up
right there Redemption won everything
but didn't win game of the year so solve
is just a profit so after Dallas is
killing it right now going to coordinate
plan I hate you I love you
like scorn
um without their support
um it's it will be almost impossible to
you know um finish working on this
project
um so we really want to share this great
joy of this evening save the speech for
the game of the year
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why can't I can't go I'm not that salty
come on
I'm it's just not my cup of tea that's
my opinion it's got to be Xbox please be
Xbox come on please the big Xbox
please be Xbox okay I just want
something dude how many times
that's a John Wick game chill yeah I
hear him so apparently Xbox One
cyberpunk all the rules
they still gotta show Final Fantasy 2 in
Hogwarts even though I don't want to see
it
not a plan
remember guys they're gonna end this
with finals we can trust now it's him
it's a whole new world too which is kind
of funny
that looks crazy
next joke
someone's always got to pay keep their
feet oh they got it
hello
he's a great actor yeah
game awards what's up just get yourself
a hand I just wanna wait oh [ __ ] yeah
1977 Phantom Liberty can't wait for you
guys to meet Reed when Phantom Liberty
releases oh it's a cop serious it's the
cop
it's a cop
bring a bell let's go thanks Idris
tonight we are thrilled to share with
you another Global game announcement
this comes from one of the most
decorated developers in the world who
consistently pushes this music forward
it's not actually it's releases this
studio has been nominated multiple times
for Game of the Year here at these
Series so we know it's not Xbox Beyond
grateful that they have chosen
he saved it but it's not Global
announcement
all right let's see where we go you know
Xbox didn't show anything bro Bandai
Xbox the next from software
okay come on man show me something I'm
like
I see blood blah blah
no this ain't bloodborne
some futuristic game
so it's a new Pac-Man game
being dynamical
don't they do the from joints yo Phil
Spencer really showed up and said we
ain't showing you [ __ ]
armored Portman is it somebody in the
twitch chat soon
this is a final fan mode
[Music]
no yeah
so what's it straight too
surviving an apocalypse
feed the fire
that's it
no let's see feed the fire would be like
bonfires Maybe
maybe it is from software oh no it is I
I oh my god the guy on the twitch chat
called an armored poor armored Core I'm
like probably like seven four or five
seconds behind y'all I don't care about
armored
you could be though
[Music]
man Microsoft really let me know
one last time
foreign
[Music]
they're like we got to make something
different because we're never gonna be
this hot after elderly ever again
Bob who knows maybe maybe this one will
pop off
[Music]
it was a PlayStation exclusive they
would have published it
dude
[Applause]
next year
we didn't see gameplay
for the first one
the first Xbox series s and X
go for it and Xbox One cross-platform
when we come back it's time to Crown the
2010 muddy yeah that's what we're here
the mushroom Mushroom Kingdom which is
lame so I don't really care about that
game it's lighted in the dark lands yeah
dude
I'm like I'm sorry man the only thing
that could Salvage is that game of the
air man
it's worthwhile I feel like DPG
[Music]
is I the only one that's like
disappointed that Microsoft didn't show
anything
it's not a good look I will say that
but hey at least we know that we can get
a free GrubHub skin freaking pubg
watch just give me the next one
okay that's why I got into gaming pubg
mobile
there was an outbreak it's frame Pace
issue simulator right here
Oh you mean this is Kalisto yeah dude
it's unplayable on PC
I love her though
from the boys
rocket League
you know what I think gaming just isn't
for me anymore
I don't think it's it's hitting me
anymore
dude's back this is so bad they had a
game with them
my body
oh my God take me down
this is the funniest joke your grown man
is really upset
he said we'll get him next time
you're killing me right now
they said we got a bad cop
yo yo y'all funny today bro y'all check
Xbox completely Tapped Out
your life it's gonna be all right guys
just one yeah
just gotta wait until next year it's a
goddamn [ __ ] I'm tired of waiting
who just really upset tonight
hold on
hold on I put on my best outfit today
I'm not I'm just because yeah
the producer and director of the
successful online
[Applause]
I must admit
please
it's on Xbox
I hope you enjoy our relationship after
six bucks
[Applause]
the smear with the game we've seen twice
before
logo that just showed up before the
trailer
God
you don't like this what are you
invested in this did it just kill that
Chocobo
they kill a chocobo yeah
did they actually kill the kid
attic we in
I'm still I'm excited let's go
I don't know what the main protagonist
that guy's the big protagonist I'm still
up to them Revenge
there's Odin those are some weak fire
particles
I know
I'ma try it obviously but I just every
time they [ __ ] that means you're gonna
try it for seventy dollars hey I'm not
gonna not play it AJ AJ you can't you
can't continue to support Sony's bad
business practices
ft set is okay
I'm not supporting it IOP is
we gotta make a review
so it's the best get out of the jail
free card I'm a content creator
out here
I'm interested with the
with their summons I'm scared they're
focusing too much on the Sun
because they did that on 50 . they did
that on 15 and I feel like it hurt the
game
I look kind of crazy
games
it's crazy dude is crazy
PlayStation 5 exclusive not available
you ready
oh yeah really nice being on stage again
actually it feels really good I know a
lot of people are nervous
sweet cool and short so
uh let's see now yeah I remember
recently uh last year winning game of
the year it's a fantastic feeling so
obviously as a nominee you should be
very happy and very proud but trust me
you do want to win because it's a great
feeling
but however you do actually win
something at the game modes are super
cool because you know this beautiful
Orchestra when they play the music for
your game I mean I was sitting over
there and trust me the hair oh hair
he's down sodium Goosebump I mean it's
really awesome service Furious give a
big Applause to the beautiful Orchestra
literally go wrong then
it's like every watch like every other
game get like 30 seconds of music
I can't celebrate sodi's greatness today
yeah
my biggest takeaway from this show is
Xbox I didn't leave Xbox Xbox left me
next year they're coming they got some
stuff
oh Starfield best believe it that's
right
in the year
the game of the year is going to be a
Star Wars Jedi Survivor oh that's yeah
that's gonna be up there
so Chad
I'm looking at yeah I know you lost the
video for a couple seconds relax it's
back up
your baby Pharmacy
don't you laugh at us
here it is here it is
so I'm gonna say God of War on here so
if
if I'm wrong at least I get points on
Twitch
got to learn man
[Music]
seriously because I'm trying to really
cover that because
I'm not gonna lie please
Jesse's emotion get to y'all cause Jesse
really put it out there I love you too
baby
thank you for sitting I'm trying man out
of fun
unleash the flute and still why is that
thick yeah don't you back up on me there
you go
I've got a PlayStation logo in the back
I do have a PlayStation logo in the back
to me
I got an Xbox
[Music]
it's quite bad it was fun
all right y'all
now do not Mutiny if God will come out
here
all right don't mute me I don't want
y'all attacking Jeff keighley I don't
want y'all tweaking at the FTC
I want y'all to be respectful and if God
will get his award y'all be quiet look
on the screen look on the screen code
foreign
give it up and you say next year
y'all really don't want this guy
yeah
there's no outside
all right let's go I'm calling God of
War though all right you guys no you're
not burning up the door West all stop it
[Music]
and start acting up don't go to the FDC
here
[Applause]
I wasn't thinking about I should have
hid the numbers the whole stream and
revealed them at the end of it nah this
was better
all right here we go here we go Rush
Game of the Year winner
elderly yeah
yeah
[Applause]
one if life is okay now is because Elder
rig one or two hey
no no no I got a better one before you
guys got what you want drop super chats
in that chat drop some super chats and
say Eldon Reed look how happy y'all are
drop some super chats in there and say
Alden ring that's what I want from you
guys now the show is a Xbox please oh my
God
thank you so much this is the funniest
chat I ever
died
okay well deserved okay the best game
what okay all right
who did this for you oh everything's
good with Phil now okay
I'm saving this yes
in the chat that God of War should have
won relieved
how you feel smooth
I feel better
congrats but that doesn't fix it
several more things we want to do
um so this getting this goatee award
really
they actually are Super Chat
they're so happy they feel like they
want to you would have seen this was a
funeral
ten minutes ago
[Laughter]
yeah
he did he did
that's an exclusive
so much
of a chat he said straight with it I
will never understand that thanks attic
with the scene Bob Dole filed some chat
this showman Xbox
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
oh God this chat just stay together
this is the greatest awards for me just
because of this chat we got the best
community hit the damn like button since
y'all so happy hit the like button now
yeah that's right get that above 400 man
that life is life is good an elder ring
one and everything's great in life
you know we should have said we should
have said
the question
goal next year on June 25th 2023 we will
be celebrating the past decade of video
game music and looking ahead to its
future you'll be hearing much more about
this history now you get my likes Peter
Pan please
smooth poster Horizon forbidden Awards
shut down for a week I love it
this was fun this is fun I would I'm
gonna rewind this I'm gonna watch the
last 20 minutes prior to elderly ridden
with some of the funniest stuff I've
ever seen in super chair history
the cargo wasn't the fact that I
wouldn't bring one it's about the fact
that God of Wars
clearly God will Condit it would have
been a sour day
I won't say something though just
watching us because I said look Jeff why
are you only butting up one like how why
do you only have one button
yeah I mean I was joking about that
his vest was like completely buttoned up
by the end of the show it's like okay
listen he listens somebody said
something to him
with the CLP 1000 so when is the
Microsoft game award show oh yeah okay
your boy you follow five Super Chat Phil
hell back Sean bangus and still got sued
without super well okay okay
Xbox flame emojis karodi okay let's move
you right all right what else we got
y'all boys
likewise later guys all right Jazz have
a good one everybody
all right we made it oh man I made it
made it we made it today I I didn't
think I don't think I could have
survived
what'd you say
I don't think I don't think smooth was
gonna last at that if that if that
didn't get voted out here man
out of the raincoat emojis Stitch oh man
too funny
out of here
starts and prayers
yeah wow people really say yeah I'll say
the shows
but they really wasn't trying to see
that happen they would not they didn't
want that picture at all bro all right
here JD gray betrays with the Xbox pull
all the their announcements from the
vj's because of Sony and they are going
scorched Earth for PlayStation to the
FTC I want to show see what body does
when Gamers show up and say we vote and
you will not be reelected skin political
political all right Zim ilocock we
finally got one Phil pull through and we
popping y'all messy man oh man okay okay
take okay Ollie I appreciate you bro
that was funny I had a lot of photos
thank you Lord don't think I can watch
this
no doubt addict let's rap man I mean
before we do that let's get um let's get
flame let's get
was going through it a little bit you
know what I'm saying but um overall was
it was it a decent show was you they
could have missed you with this show you
didn't seem too happy smooth yeah I
thought the show was I didn't like the
show honestly and it's not really much
of the game of war show I think I'm I'm
still trying to get over uh things that
has nothing to do with the game wars
that is really I guess clouding my
judgment on today's show so you know
when I get over that I'm disappointed
that there was the lack of like Xbox
presents here
um that it's very it's felt
um
uh but then again I wasn't a big fan of
the award of the award nominations and
stuff like that so I didn't have no real
dog in any of the nomination shout out
to like interior night before they're
pulling off that win
um obviously the Elder ring I'm happy I
won that
um got it uh it was very very
predictable uh I wasn't a big fan of
yeah I don't feel like there was a game
that said boom where we were all shocked
like I don't feel like we had that
shocking moment that like the the
shocking moments of like 2019 and 2020
is the reason why I watched the show
last year and watched the show this year
is because you you're expecting similar
things that happen
um but overall I mean like I I he
attempt had not been for you know
freaking gold hair judge
um his show actually might have been
shorter yes
I like how it was concise
um they they did give people opportunity
to speak I still don't like the whole
rapid fire you know yeah like rewards
and stuff like that but they had music
this time when they did the rapper fight
they had
doing something no I was I was
disappointed uh that Rebellion didn't
win
that would have made for so much content
yeah all brought out a bit the streets
would have been on fire
but over Robbie I'm not it was it was
all right it was all right at the end
I'm happy with the uh outcome but it
wasn't I I feel like there has been
better award shows most notably 2019
2020 I think we're pretty was pretty
good uh last year uh was was decent I
enjoyed this show last year this year
no not as much
Lord Flame the messiest most negative
hating on trailer before it gets
announced person how'd you like
next week
yeah yeah thanks I actually know exactly
how to tilt this we clicked off the game
awards too early because supposedly
right after that little counter or
whatever there's like some kid that went
on stage and said that he had now and
said that he was nominating an award to
Bill Clinton I'm like
I said yeah who was that push that went
on stage I'm sorry dude at the end that
the camera I said that to you
um Anchorman uh he lit oh that was a
situation
yeah it was like a minor situation he
just like walked on and said something
about Bill Clinton or something he
grabbed a mic it went crazy
yes oh that's wow well not crazy crazy
but like low I think I want to nominate
this award for my reform going to go
swimming by Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
how did this man even get on the stage I
don't know that's crazy how did they get
a mic that's crazy but anyway did you
know he was speaking into the mic that
um you know they Urban speaks into did
they like rush to the stage
they grabbed them like like in the NFL
send it to me I want to see it somebody
sent me that link somebody said I sent
it to you I sent it to you
they're about to play that on the stream
real quick no we not gonna play those
trees because we not fair the audio is
already out there okay no that's good
that's cool yeah send me the link that's
offline
the show was actually kind of bad uh
look I appreciate that a lot of the
award like whatever they were doing the
awards like I think it even said like
there were still a lot of those rapid
fire ones and it felt just completely
unbalanced because you have [ __ ] that I
can't play it guys so I can't play yeah
okay okay fair enough but it's out there
uh just go over to Anchorman V2 on
Twitter and you can watch the clip all
right
here you guys can I'll put it in the
chat you guys can go here and look at it
yourself
well anyways you can have Christopher
Judge going on stage talking about his
life for like 10 minutes and then wait
for a while over the span of 30 seconds
yeah like wow I mean to be fair you know
dying in the very beginning of the
stream was kind of healthy because it
was like I was prepared to be
filled with rage not watching Al Pacino
not understand what he's supposed to be
saying or doing and then having
Christopher Judge kind of get it you
give it use to this like look you're not
getting a good game of the word you're
not gonna get game of the year so you
might as well just get your bars off
while you can that kind of made sense um
the announcements though
some good ones like I actually did it's
not just the Airship Syndicate one I
actually didn't think they were going to
announce armor for that early and yeah
sit that early
although it might come out on July 24
but still like it was
kind of like a decent show overall it
was better Pace but then at the end it
just started to drag you could feel the
you could feel everything kind of
fizzling out I feel yeah no particular
any one particular game that got you
most excited at all from it or nothing
really stand out like should I Survivor
yes
all over that game I'm sure you guys
were like ragged on me like I was
attacking her so I was like I don't know
Shadow survivors
is going to be a massive Improvement of
the original one so that's gonna be
great and I hope they put calcasus in a
you know Disney Plus show Once because
uh
they kind of need you know some good
stories for once no doubt Lord
addicted
flying in oh wait oh man oh yeah JD
gamer and yo they celebrating that God
that got a worn out winning game with
all they pop it off Bob Dole five
dollars to the chat worst game award
show in years a clear sodium that's what
so Blake so blatant with the exclusives
too so great disgusting steady say high
pitch makes me sick right all right okay
he gave me inflection points all right
and then we got JD give me again ten
dollars for check it's all politics
Biden and his ft and his FTC will reap
the rewards of beep with multiple
trillion companies they will find out
that they can and will be replaced with
all the companies donating to ask them
okay okay
frustration going on No Doubt
man you seem to be the most positive I
think it's the best show they've had
look there was a lot of things I didn't
care about positivity I do think that
they had the hip pay seem pretty good
for the majority of the show they had
good stuff that uh you know I I will
agree with smooth there wasn't a what
the hell moment like oh my God but it's
just like I don't feel like I can say
the show is bad just because that wasn't
there like they had death straining I
didn't really expect that dude you know
they were able to get Jedi the first
like real gameplay showing on that that
was good huge that showed out yeah they
showed a lot of interesting appealing
games but you know one thing I I am
disappointed Microsoft didn't show up
here yeah but my only caveat is if they
didn't show up here because they want to
hold their own analysis
then I'm okay with it but if they don't
do nothing and they just drop YouTube
videos that's what I'll be against it
because it's like if you're just going
to drop a YouTube video show on the
release date to Starfield why even show
and part of me feels like Starfield
might get delayed to Holiday because
what events are they going to show that
are they just gonna drop a YouTube video
what in June the game's supposed to be
out before then
because they see a question your
question is when are they going to show
it is a good question is that actually
that's your question for them so that
you could serve because they didn't show
it here yeah but you try to understand
yeah yeah because my mindset's like this
is the biggest show by far until E3 yes
so are they not going to show it they
didn't show it here so when are they
going to show are they not going to show
up because they know it's not coming out
before E3 or are they going to or they
have another event that like maybe they
have like an XO plan that's before E3
this year uh I I don't know like I I
don't think that they're going to keep
it till E3 I do feel like they're going
to do something maybe inside Xbox
dedicated to Star filled and redfall and
that and if they do that I'm cool with
it but if they're just going to drop a
YouTube video with a release date I'm
not cool with that they should have had
it here at that point because I don't
I don't mind them coming out on other
people's events but if they don't use it
at their own events you should have just
dropped it here okay all right um hold
on JD game again follow some chat
leadercon will quietly ask to resign
once the FTC starts getting trouts in
court with their weak ass case and
didn't buy they could have scream you to
cover his okay yeah they arrested the
kid on stage I did see they right now
that they arrested him yeah he got
because when you see the air you see
them starting to converge on him
they probably they probably escort them
out of the building but I doubt they
arrested him
[Music]
the question I do want to ask you guys
is they lost game of Direction and Game
of the Year God awarded do you think
that kind of like like takes the cell
out of all the other ones that they won
because it's like equivalent to like
going to the Super Bowl and losing the
Super Bowl like they got everything else
but the Super Bowl what's up so I've
called it he literally called it man he
said oh yeah and here's the final tally
it's over here to the left I made sure
to keep it here on the screen it was
actually annoying because I had to like
really mess with stuff Lark uh so we got
me a dead ass last at 10 points we got
uh we got King and ACG tied for uh for
the uh what that would be the third
third place and that is they both worth
12 points Cognito coming in at second
place with 13 points
in Sovereign first place again coming in
with 15 points yo effective immediately
we're looking for another iron Lord to
replace Lord saw
okay
after the Year got to be able to reach
super chats you have to have fluid you
have to be fluent in Spanish that is
what it was required now if you could
speak another language that's a plus yes
plus we take a bonus languages you know
say I'm tired of this being out
outperforming me all the time it's
Luther my brother he killed that um I'm
not trying to lay dwell on this but uh
Jeff Kelly did say he actually is
arrested yeah
it's like a soccer game crazy yeah yeah
play play whipper
um five dollar Canadian hey at least no
level infinite and 10 cent plastic all
over the place this time I agree at
least I felt the pacing on the
advertisement was much better you know
say they had a couple of still crazy
moments like flame said they did the
money they could have missed me with the
Muppets uh in a couple other things but
I thought for compared to last year's
ads this was a marketed Improvement
you're saying [ __ ] overall but yes
there's still spots JD gave it 10 ounce
of a chat this FTC nonsense is going to
cost Microsoft billions and the rest of
the game industry is just watching what
Sony did expect a defection just like
what happened to Nintendo in the 90s
Sony will get what's due so you think
it's payback I think it's karma coming
okay we'll we'll speak on that Sunday
yeah it's it's going to be a lit show
yes it's going to be a long show because
we have a guess yeah it's going to be a
late show uh well like I said I will say
um overall a mixed bag I thought it was
better than last year I thought they
were some strong reveals I thought
Diablo was fantastic I have a tech and
I'm buying I don't get what y'all that's
what I'm saying
the game Street Fighter the game it was
a good show was fire it just again I
understand you know what it is
sorry
if this FTC news didn't happen the day
before the awards the energy will be
different but because the FTC situation
happened Microsoft gets sued for the
Activision thing the morale leading in
is down from an Xbox fan perspective
right and I get it so now let's be real
you coming into it like yo we we need
something to get to get there get to get
the win back you know that and I get it
I I understand you know I'm saying and I
think that's why I had the cloud the
chat because y'all was funny into that
what y'all was hilarious y'all was
throwing Tomatoes at the screen but now
life was all good because now Xbox got
to win that you want it and I get it I
understand but we gotta thank you bad
juju yeah
someone posted a picture of that kid I'm
gonna let you finish but Bill Clinton
made one of the best games of all time
[Applause]
he kind of did that
but uh yeah yeah they put Bill Clinton
in front of Elden ring signs
but like I thank you as a gamer it was a
good show but if they look we still got
a
still got to work on some stuff there
was still some cringe I don't know how I
feel excuse me I don't know how I feel
about the music part all the time during
the joint oh Al Pacino we gotta come for
you albertino please especially besides
I love you brother but man you made them
come up with music to get people off the
stage after you like this I get it it's
a moment emotional his boss was just way
too crazy and he was giving us the four
scores seven years ago he was giving me
my first steps out the womb we got it
all we got the full I'm like bro like I
get it but this is not the time for that
length it was just too crazy but um yeah
that was it and um you know that's funny
he did that because he he knew that they
weren't winning game of the year so he
needed to get that speech out now
he got it all for the team
that's all I got anybody got anything
else what happened what happened
like you know how when someone invades
you and eldering they show up red yes
smooth they they they they let that dude
in red and said you've been invaded
yo they filed they filed for that they
found dude the internet quick the
internet yeah he's a bad thoughts he he
thought he was getting a life Savage
Shiva Army brat you are on fire that's
how Christian Chris judge thought this
was the Chris judge Lifetime Achievement
Award and we was here to celebrate his
greatness over the years and bro I
respect you you would you you're the boy
you that dude but not like that bro you
have to learn your time I don't know if
it was other influences I don't know
what made you stay on that show too long
JD gaming 10 on the Super Chat solely
has caused its own premature demise Call
of Duty is awful limits to them no
matter what in three years and
Microsoft's gonna be locking down
exclusive to 10 year Game Pass contract
and I would take all the fight damn
Danny gamer you go to school at start
with this you go you're going you're
going all the way with this
what happened I I I do gotta say you
know thank you to the academy I was I
really have to go to the bathroom so
really really appreciate him showing
that trailer that was long enough for me
to go to the bathroom with a snack and
still be able to chill with you it was a
great break yeah shout out shout out to
them for making a second I mean in
Nashville time it is what it is but
that's all I got y'all cause otherwise
it's late I gotta get it we got to do a
one uh a grade oh the great yeah you're
right I completely forgot I could
believe for that all right let's change
it up let's do an A B C or D or F for
phone
okay wow case move what's your grade
overall he would have gave it an FFL and
ring last game yeah we're looking at it
I'm looking at a I'm looking at a B
minus
that's way better
gave you a lot
there's going to be a massive billion
dollar smear km pick the kids
Microsoft tribe peace but now it's well
you know what's funny Microsoft Access
as if it is beef for real
I wonder what that means but it was so
Garcia Crystal would it be by this Flame
can't be no higher than the sea for you
the way you was talking
all right let me let me stop bleeding
let me stop leading man
be honest kids
I'll just go let's see
um okay that's it I got nothing else to
say like no no no no no that's fine
that's fine that's just so that you're
you're on brand
on brand yeah you're on Brands I'm just
gonna call it mid and move no doubt
addict what to see
you give it a b yeah I do think that
part of the Video Game Awards is to make
sure that they secure as many people in
the industry uh I do think that Jeff not
being able to convince Microsoft to come
on there does knock it uh that would
have that would have been a good show if
you could have got like a star filled
release date oh man
yeah it would have been it would have
been legendary but I I think it was a
good show B
J before about before JD gave it to last
through the chat rest in peace Sony you
wanted the war was what you gonna get yo
this Sunday this Sunday is going to be
saving for something crazy yeah it
should be out now all right you know
what actually I'll give them a b because
of the because of the kid that came on
and said oh my God that has nothing to
do with the game that wasn't my point
not but I had to stop looking at my
phone because there's so many memes man
I obviously Lady
this is tough um two dollars two percent
from JD gamer don't be a bully Sony if
you can't actually like yeah
the Hades two Jedi it can't get no lord
of the beat it wasn't it was a fake show
it wasn't perfect there was some spots
here and there but
overall Improvement way better games
that I felt mostly and I thought they I
thought they made some improvements
there's always so many things you got
not gonna like about this show I already
know this show is never going to be that
type of show all the way but I felt he
did a good enough job
for the most part tell you a lot of the
feedback now they just got to work on
when the dudes do get the awards play
the music earlier now you learned your
less a good judge they're gonna have to
have a Chris judge security section
and make sure that dudes could read the
teleprompter up close
please you know what I'm saying but
overall outside of it the way it started
was Rocky but after it slowed down they
got past that and they were okay I just
the reason that I think it's such a huge
Improvement a I do think they gave
people plenty of time to get their
points they did they got the feedback
yeah and then uh I look there was
advertisers but it didn't feel forced it
felt like it was relevant to what was
going on and you didn't feel like you
were sitting I know maybe the the
GrubHub could have been down a little
bit but it's like look he got to make
his money but it wasn't over excessive
that's all I cared about I agree I agree
no doubt that's what I got everybody
working to find people find yourself a
Kiss Boom where can they find you
probably get up out of here find me on
Twitter actually smooth find me on
YouTube at kids smooth and um
yeah man good night man good guys fight
him in GameStop selling that PS5
yo shout out to Sean Sean Kramer and c75
we always hike these things too much in
our heads that's fast Jeff works hard to
get a lot yeah we got to get Miss
Flowers I mean it's not perfect but look
we we've always wanted something like
this we always with the Geeks always we
always wanted our award show we got what
jdk with two lines this is the beginning
of the end for PlayStation third party
save it for sure JD gamer is hot he
outside he's not having it bro he's not
save it for Sunday man come on he got
bars now they go on they gonna pay for
this what they did but anyway Lords of
gamer.net the unbiased one okay
I totally unbiased anyways I do want to
give a special shout out to the team
real quick because both uh Nick sorry
three people uh Nick Jean and was yes
they killed it I had I was only able to
get my pre-written stuff out so I want
to give them a special thank you for
holding it down and really giving
like the news edition of The Flame he
was writing articles and watching them
and doing it at the same time and he had
enough time we got Thomas slander he's
doing all of this I balanced this very
well yeah how do you anyways huh
I'm on Twitter at uh flame lognet on
Woods gaming.net I'm Joseph Repco if you
see any Warframe articles it's most
likely going to be me and
um they want to play A3 on Xbox whenever
they finally have a game drop uh you
know it's a living Ignus on there so not
like this not like you know you see how
damn it was a down moment today not like
this don't care I could show I could
show you my DMs from uh Ray oftenheimer
he is just happy so okay fair enough
fair enough he's worse than me and
that's saying something fair enough
playing uh
no doubt Lord addict thank you for
hosting sir a lot of times yeah thanks
THX level 138 2000 Super Chat Microsoft
Sony King Kong ain't got nothing though
oh we about it always scorching it yo
put the guns away Microsoft fans stay
away from the guns tonight y'all are
shooting stop shooting leave it alone
Bob Dole chat something no one is
talking about since Sony didn't sign the
contract a judge can rule the deal to go
through with no concessions Sony without
Khan I actually have a feeling that if
this goes to and they win it through
Court they will not be concessions it
will be interesting if it's a high
stakes game with poker and the 10 years
if it goes to court doesn't get upheld
who knows what this the thing about this
we ain't never going to stop here then
living that's that's the sad part about
to do for me the sad part about it is
gonna stop talking about this oh my God
we're going to be hearing about this for
all of the next year court case and this
is
how they they said around like August
20th and sadly we have to talk about her
Sunday because it's such a such a thing
absolutely never gonna go away I'm so
sick of putting Call of Duty in the
title of an island
I'm so sick and it doesn't stop but yeah
we're back at it y'all but uh yeah
you can follow me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP you can find me on YouTube at
gaming addict go follow me on YouTube
Man Gaming addict I've been putting out
a lot more videos
um I'm gonna put out I don't know if I'm
gonna put out a video about the video
Awards I think I want to make a video
about cholesterol protocol because I've
already really talked about the Video
Game Awards I'm not going to be making
too much uh
too too much words when it comes to this
uh Call of Duty thing I'm going to save
that for IOP pretty sure we're coming
through man I'm glad you guys like the
Tyler thing that took me like three
hours to figure out thank you I love
that like it was ridiculous uh you know
but uh I I found it the same way people
do the death counters and on you on
Twitch
[Music]
but it adds it gives me it keeps the
competition I kept looking over it's
like it was like a sports game I kept
looking overhead Disco Boy damn it song
yeah we missed one award the plan choice
too um Sean cream smoothie said when is
the next track cover you about to you're
about to jump in the lab yo yo smooth
you need to do a diss track about this
deal did you go over to the lab right
now I don't know man I have no idea but
yeah I should uh check out on your
PlayStation's uh the four spoken demo
but it was out now it's out now
okay cool I'll check that out and uh you
know meet like Cognito I know y'all
turned on me I was very angry with me
but I was just having fun with your
emotions yeah I was very emotional it
was really fun playing with y'all poking
the beer I had fun
it was good good overall good to see us
with everybody in the chat salute to my
brother saw dominating us as usual as
we've been doing every year it was kind
of bad this year it was kind of bad we
got ran out the building even like it
was literally he even predicted how the
show was gonna go that's when you know
he's on another level he told me Cog is
going to go God will go with everything
except Game of the Year it's going to be
2018 in Reverse I was like this man
you know he didn't he couldn't do it
with this I'm pretty sure all right we
gotta check and make sure he wasn't at
this event so I've got the plug yours
but yeah check that out that's all I got
at it get us out of here and I'll see
y'all on Sunday it's gonna be lit see ya
peace have a great night y'all
say bye